весілля 2022 патріотизм і безпека
Сьогодні у нас віртуальна студія яка
знаходиться Ось так Скажімо так на
просторах інтернету з метою безпеки ми
не можемо зараз сказати де ми але згодом
трошки пізніше всі про це дізнаються
хочу одразу сказати що сьогодні в цій
нашій віртуальній студії разом зі мною
присутні головний спеціаліст відділу
позашкільної освіти та виховної роботи
Міністерства освіти і науки України
Тетяна Кононович і
кандидат педагогічних наук старший
науковий співробітник провідний науковий
співробітник лабораторії позашкільної
освіти інституту проблем виховання
Національної академії педагогічних наук
України Анна Корнієнко
Шановні колеги ми сьогодні будемо
розмовляти про
виклики які поставила з війна перед
позашкільниками Ми сьогодні будемо
розмовляти про кращі практики наших з
вами колег про кращі можливості
реалізації
талантів наших дітей про ті дуже потужні
дії які створило саме позашкілля ось в
ці 6 місяців війни
хочу одразу наголосити що наша
Конференція буде сьогодні складатися з
трьох панелей панель номер один
це пріоритети національно-патріотичного
виховання під час війни і в закладах
позашкільної освіти тема другої панелі
це позашкільники патріоти свого фронту
тема панелі номер 3 кращі практики на
150 175 днів війни Тому перед тим як
розпочинати наші панелі от буквально
кілька годин тому завершилася пленарна
конференція Міністерство освіти і науки
України на якій Міністр освіти і науки
України Сергій шкарлет
розказував основні
ключові позиції
Міністерства щодо вирішення ось цих
глобальних викликів які постали взагалі
перед освітою України і однією з
пріоритетних задач найближчого часу є
звичайно завдання розпочати навчальний
рік Звичайно що початок нового
навчального року це колосальний виклик і
тому є рішення які на пленарній
конференції були озвучені і міністром
освіти і науки України і нашими гостями
Тобто там були і
представники міжнародної спільноти із
зарубіжжя долучалися Хочу наголосити на
тому що переглянути конференцію можна на
youtube-каналі Міністерства освіти і
науки України а єдине що в нашій секції
так само як і на 11 інших секціях
локаціях
нашої серпневої конференції за кожною
окремою темою відбувається своє
наповнення свій зміст відповідно до
самої локації але на кожній з локації ми
маємо зазначити дуже важливий меседж я
прошу зараз Вивести на екран окремий
слайд це
моделі це
4 моделі Освіти 4 моделі освіти які
можуть бути опановані вихованцями на ось
цьому періоді початку нового навчального
року
А
дайте мені слайд де 4
моделі у той що я привіз з конференції
так ось цей слайд
Як ви бачите тут є
4 моделі наших глядачів Все прекрасно
бачать
[музика]
є 4 моделі про які детально детально
розказав наш міністр в своєму вступному
слові найголовніше що Ці моделі які
запропонувала
Міністерство освіти науки України вони
універсальні тобто користуватися цими
модемами можна Ну скажімо так враховуючи
вибір дитини тому я вас дуже прошу
звернути увагу Ось на цей слайд
потім запису можна подивитися його і вже
відповідно до цього звертатися на сайт
Міністерства там є детальні інструкції з
приводу того як яким чином воно може
працювати
ми рухаємось далі У нас дуже великий
сьогодні обсяг робіт на нашій
конференції і
я хочу
розпочати
панель номер один панель з назвою
пріоритети
національно-патріотичного виховання під
час війни в закладах позашкільної освіти
до нас у нас на звездочку має бути
Андрій Андрійович лісота директор
української державного центру
національно-педагогічного виховання
краєзнавства і туризму учнівської молоді
Пане Андрію ви з нами
Слава Україні Доброго дня З вами чутно
вас радий бачити
радий бачити такий сьогодні дуже
натхненний в нас відбувається чудові
заходи
дякувати Богу сьогодні на пленарному
засіданні Дякую міністру за те що він
закцентував велику увагу на національну
патріотичному вихованню також зацептував
увагу на наші заходах Дякую за підтримку
ми рухаємося в цьому напрямку і не
будемо спинятися І ви розумієте Чому
Тому що вже
настав такий час що вже процес
національно-патріотичного виховання
військового патріотичного виховання
має бути номер один нам би вам в країні
і ми маємо це всі розуміти маємо всі над
цим працювати в країні війна війна
заклятим
слідом яка вже триває насправді більше
300 років а зараз ми стали свідками
такої з їхнього боку дуже кривавої до
нас відношення тому ми як ніхто освітяни
маємо в цьому протистояти на своєму
освітньому фронті і тут важливо є деякі
ключові моменти
і чинники - це те що наша гуманітарна
освіта вся її основне змістовне
наповнення є одним із ключових чинників
формування національної свідомого
громадянина і той хто контролює
гуманітарну освіту той задає тон у цьому
напрямку це універсальне правило для
всіх країн і
гуманітарну освіту очолюємо Ми з вами
всі освітяни ми зараз маємо об'єднатися
не тільки позашкільники а і школа
профтехосвіта вища школа
дошкільна освіта для того щоб працювати
єдиним фронтом
у цьому напрямку
на сьогодні
завдячуючи підтримки віри Борисівни
рогової ми
розуміючи ситуацію
сконцентрували свою увагу на цьому
напрямку з і підготували для вас Всі ви
її отримали Я хочу на цьому зупинитися
це концепцію
національно-патріотичного виховання Ми
її оновили з урахуванням війни також
заклали фундамент на післявоєнний період
після того як ми переможемо
Тому
змінюємо такі акценти
ми маємо почати працювати ви всі
розумієте з дитячого садочка і працювати
з нашою молоддю
аж Скажімо так закінчення студентських
років і не тільки саме про це в цій
концепції ми говоримо Що це має прийти
наскрізним таким
камінним по по всім нашим видам освіти і
ми маємо позашкільники взяти цей прапор
і очолити цей рух немає значення Чи це
екологи натуралісти Чи це туристи
краєзнавці чи національно-патріотичні
заклади чи художньо-естетичний напрямок
Ми маємо всі над цим працювати разом
спільно зі школою дитячим садком і
іншими
видами
закладів значить в концепції і на
сьогоднішній день ми бачимо як важливі
для нас і особливо це було сьогодні
видно наші гасла атрибути їм вітання
Слава Україні і ми бачимо що ця
концепція і цей напрямок дуже близький
для українців гасла ідеї живі і робочі
Не кажучи вже там про червону червоний
червоно-чорний прапор який сьогодні
майоріє на фронті така виховна система
можливо і не даєш швидкого результату
але в час боротьби вона перезапускається
і працює
для цього потрібен нам час і цей час Ми
вже пройшли і ми бачимо що ці ця
концепція
і гасла вона діє
для цього
не дивлячись на зусилля російської
пропаганди які були до цього часу і які
особливо зараз є під час війни на
окупованих зараз тимчасово окупованих
територій територіях
Я хочу сказати що Також ми маємо
ще одну таку
модель запроваджувати всі запроваджуємо
всі концепції ми говоримо що наша нова
країна після війни - це країна вільних
людей
ми постійно повторюємо і будемо говорити
про це
під час різних заходів і
про це говоримо
це виховує молодь для якої Україна вища
навіть за особистий добробут Ми прагнемо
щоб кожна молода людина коли приходить
[музика]
будь-яку структуру навчальний заклад
Вона відчувала себе особистістю і
говорила що я найкраще я українець тут
дуже важливо ми маємо про це говорити
і тут такий
лозунг Можуть сказати що він не є
популярним але ми бачимо що кожна дитина
має розуміти що країна починається з
тебе Тобто безпосередньо з людини і
Україна - це не просто Соняхи і синє
небо це люди прапор гімн кожна
інфраструктурна одиниця
хороша людина погана з безхатьками чи
неприбраним подвір'ям Але це твоя країна
і ти за неї відповідаєш І ти відчуваєш
себе гордим за Україну От такий ключові
моменти
також
хотіли хочеться щоб ми
сформували патріота лише я говорив
попередньо про гасла
не патріота лише гасел а патріота
свідомого і ми це бачимо дуже приємно це
бачити зараз серед дітей і молоді На
жаль ми не завжди це спостерігаємо серед
дорослого населення і також ми хочемо
щоб ця
в концепції у нас
відповідало саме такому напрямку
[музика]
Сьогодні ми також маємо говорити про
релігію про духовне спілкування про
церкву
про церкву
українську і якби ми раніше викорінили
російський вплив церковній сфері то ми б
на сьогодні не мали церкву інструментом
військової агресії і у нас би очевидно
якби це ми зробили давно війни б не було
на жаль Церква впливала через батьків на
дітей і впливає на дітей Тому ми маємо
не забувати і про це
також концепції ми передбачаємо ряд
заходів і Одні із таких самих які ми
бачимо на сьогоднішній день це
військово-патріотичні вишколи серед
молоді учнів
це
ми маємо робити спільну із міністерством
молоді та спорту адже вони також
відповідальні за розвиток
національно-патріотичного виховання і ми
вже почали багато з вас робить цю роботу
і
Ця робота дуже важлива на сьогоднішній
день
[музика]
ці вишкільні табори дають нам
чудову підготовку якщо ми проведемо це в
систему але А в нас є ідеї Проведення
таких таборів ми вже розпочали
роботу це підготовка дітей до життя у
природі де до колективу що кожен є
членом команди
живе в наметі бігає мокне під дощем їсть
їжу
приготовлену набагаті і такий приклад
таких таборів він виховує молодь і
звичайно ми насичуємо ці вишкільні
табори різними елементами підготовки
до збройних сил України і також
виховуємо молодь
на сьогоднішній день
також ми бачимо дуже важливу в концепції
таку тему це робота
з батьками через дітей
нас дуже багато є таких прикладів коли
ми проводимо табір Ну я не хочу Зараз
нікого образити приїжджають діти східної
України І побувавши в наших таборах Де
ми
проводимо певну з ними роботу цікаву з
національно-патріотичного виховання
Навіть те що вони одягають вишиванки і
інші речі Вони повертаються до своїх
батьків
які вже є переселенцями я був навіть
свідком таких розмов і
розповідають що мама тато нема тут
ніякої пункти ніхто нікого не гнобити і
оце Також ми бачимо в цьому дуже великий
пріоритет робота з дітьми і саме
для внесення такого виховного процесу за
допомогою дітям
батькам батькам
на сьогоднішній день ми бачимо
важливість взяти і це ми будемо говорити
в цій концепції взяти практики роботи
Скажімо так національно-патріотичного
виховання інших країн на нашу думку дуже
цікавими в цьому напрямку є Канада
Сполучені Штати Америки Велика Британія
Австралія ми бачимо насамперед співпрацю
між ними В цьому плані тому що дуже
цікаві практики це звичайно цікаві
практики і континентальної Європи але
вони відміняються такою політикою
мультикультуризму
культуралізму
у нас нація молода і тому трошечки нам
їхні практики на нашу думку не підходять
більше ми схильні до практик Канади
Сполучених Штатів якщо ви заперечуєте
готові відповісти
на ваші питання тому наприклад в
американців діє політика котла коли
Кожен
переправляється так скажімо в лапках у
спільному котлі стає американці канадців
теж це зрозуміли в цій країні мешкають
різні національності у тому числі й
українці це може бути Джон наприклад
такий не знаю української мови але має
на малишині величезний Тризуб і
усвідомлює що він українець але всі вони
одночасно пишаються тим що вони
канадці точно така ж політика Я сказав
це є в американців І що дуже цікаво
вчора буквально спілкувалися з паном
Сергієм нашим вельмишановним сьогодні
модератором
е-е нашої секції то американські діти
Зараз
граються у них Герої не герої марвела
герої України тобто герої українців Вони
граються в ігри і називається себе
українцями граються
війнушку в гри в різні ігри це дуже
такий
Цікавий
приклад того
що нас зараз в світі поважають і ми
маємо це
використовувати під час
цієї війни з оркестаном
тому Ось такі
як Скажімо так
основні моменти ще хотілося сказати
ми маємо зараз прививати дітям молоді те
що немає бути формального
ставлення до символу я говорив сьогодні
про вишиванку ми це Вишиванка це гарно
актуально престольно але вона не
самоціль вишиванка має означати Що ти
несеш собі культуру Україну а не просто
Ми одягнули бо потрібно сфотографуватись
[музика]
Тобто ми в концепції в своєму баченні
проти
такого формалізму і ми маємо донести з
вами
Що це престижно актуально і пристойно І
саме головне що ти несеш собі Україну і
її культуру
[музика]
якщо Тобто ми бачимо якщо наприклад
українська пісня або танець сорочка
будуть подані примітивно несучасно то
дитина їх не сприймає Тому ми маємо
зацікавити їх у цьому і пояснити що ці
атрибутика і там і українська музика що
це все тисячолітня історія і вона
ідентифікує тебе як справжнього українця
і і справжню
людину також хочу сказати що нас що ми
дуже з нетерпінням чекаємо сьогодні
прийняття закону Верховної Ради про
національно-патріотичне виховання
На жаль поки що він не прийнятий не
будем надіятися що це буде найближчим
часом і ми будемо чітко розуміти на
сьогоднішній день державну
території Ось цього питання Хоча вона
насправді на сьогодні уже все зрозуміло
і
все потрібно робити швидко тому що війна
триває і нам потрібно
перемагати також
[музика]
хотів би сказати про одну важливу річ
яка
сталася
сталася нещодавно
[музика]
це
відбулася
така цікава співпраця і зустріч
в апараті Ради національної безпеки і
оборони Вона є дуже важливою для нас
саме в контексті
національно-патріотичного виховання я
трошки далі розповім але за результатами
цієї
наради апарати РНБО
України
рекомендує центральним органом влади і
органом місцевого
самоврядування наступні речі Вони для
нас є дуже важливим
самими важливими Я вважаю на
сьогоднішній день це головам цивільних
військових адміністрацій головам громад
зберегти існуючу мережу закладів
позашкільної освіти та існуючий рівень
видатків на їхнє утримання Я думаю що це
буде підтримано на рівні Кабінету
Міністрів і інших і Верховної Ради
найближчим часом і це для нас є такою
невеличкою перемогою особливо в
контексті тих подій які відбуваються
останнім часом
хочу сказати що
привітати наших позашкільників з тим і я
впевненістю хочу про це говорити і
завжди говорю що
наше позашкілля будь-якого напрямку
завжди
було тим локомотивом
національно-патріотичного виховання
нашій країні
Сьогодні ми бачимо купу прикладів коли
діти вихованці наші саме наші
знаходяться там на передку і захищають
нашу країну від від оркостану від оцієї
орди Я знаю багато вихованців По нашому
напрямку багато викладачів це буде далі
які дійсно захищають нашу країну і з
перших днів і ще з 14-го року це робили
це говорить про те що позашкільна освіта
в напрямку національно-патріотичного
виховання
працювала правильно вірно і буде надалі
працювати Тому ми зараз маємо об'єднати
зусилля з усіма видами освіти для того
щоб не тільки на рівні позашкільної
освіти запроваджувати
е-е
національно-патріотичне виховання
військово-патріотичне виховання
окремо Хочу зупинитися декілька слів
сказати про нашу всеукраїнську Сокіл
Джуру я на відкритті
заходу сказав сьогодні ключових три
слова що Джура була є і буде і дуже
приємно що цей важкий час на Захід
зібралося 15 регіонів з усієї України це
середня і старша група Все буде добре
працюємо
в цьому напрямку і схочу привести
Цікавий приклад
горкостані недавно проводилась виставка
армія 22 І вони показували
приклад українського класу і наскрізною
темою цього класу було ви бачили в
Фейсбуці багато постів з цього приклад
показували національну патріотичне
виховання в Україні і висіла футболка
Джури Тобто це говорить Ще раз що ми
рухаємося у вірному напрямку
[музика]
в мене ще є час з пане Сергію чи вже
є в мене час
дивіться насправді В нас дуже щільний
графік перша дуже потужна дуже зрозуміло
Я думаю що в кінці нашої панелі якщо у
наших учасників будуть запитання то тоді
можливо ще там кілька хвилин
5-10-15 Якщо там буде то тоді будуть
відповіді Добре дякую в принципі Дякуємо
вам що змогли долучитися що змогли
поставити такі акценти досить важливі я
бачу сьогодні на пленарній конференції
зранку а оте відео з
ваших Карпат де зібралися потужні
потужні сили Джури І знаєте ось це таке
місце сили звідки ось прямо це
енергетика енергетика патріоти
енергетика
важлива для всіх назв вона прямо аж
через страй іде тому Ну це це дуже
важливо і це теж є певним взірцем для
інших дітей і для інших учасників нашого
ось такого освітнього процесу а
залишаємося на звичку і
в нашій панелі в нашій панелі також бере
участь
державне експерт експертної групи з
питань позашкільної та інклюзійної
освіти Віктор Васильович сальков пане
Вікторе ви на зв'язку з нами так так
Доброго дня Сергію в мене добре чути так
вас прекрасно чути пане Вікторе а і вас
прекрасно видно і чути Тож будь ласочка
Прокоментуйте будь ласка ось пріоритети
національного патріотичного виховання в
закладах дошкільної освіти з вашого з
вашого експертного погляду
Ну по-перше я хочу привітати на цій
панелі потужну професійну сміливу
позашкільну спільноту І подякувати
кожному позашкільнику за цей шалену
працю яка була проведена з початку війни
до того під час ковіду про забезпечення
дистанційної освіти за той моральний
патріотичний дух який ви вселяєте в
наших дітей а цей дух наші діти
транслюють
не лише на всю Україну
не лише на всю Європу і на весь світ
своїми роботами своєю мотивацією своїми
компетентністю за це вам
дорогі любі мої позашкільники від мене
особисто Від міністерства низький уклін
і я щасливий від того що як було на
початку ковід так і на початку війни
козашкільники перші
стали щитом у забезпеченні дітей
в закладах поза закладами
роботою з ними Незалежності від натов
будь художньо-естетичний чи
еколого-натулістичний
сталося що
сьогоднішня Серпнева конференція
вперше за багато десятків років різних
педагогічних конференцій є воєнну
конференцію тому сьогодні акценти ми
ставимо на національну патріотичному
військово-патріотичному вихованні проте
особливо в цей особливий період ми
повинні зрозуміти що ці процеси
національно-патріотичного і інші виховні
вони є наскрізними
що не обов'язково
бути українцем із автоматом в руках
можна бути українцем який доводить
усьому світу що ми інтелектуальна нація
Що Ми нація які поважаємо і честь і
гідність кожного українця кожного сусіда
України які чемнуть які розділяє
цінності і захищає цінності
Саме ці погожу викладені у новій
редакції закону про дошкільну освіту
який вже пройшов перше читання в
Верховній Раді України ми зараз працюємо
із народними депутатами України що
щодоопрацювання
цього нового Закону з чому звичайно
існують нові виклики
чому звичайно мотивація позашкільників
має бути більшою і більш достойною ніж
єни
Чому Тому що війна показала що різні
моделі навчання повинні застосовувати
позашкільну тому що війна показала що
наші позашкільники самі
утворюють нові моделі які є більш
прийнятними більш мобільним ті що
працюють але вони не закріплені в
законодавстві тому Я вдячний
всім вам вдячний міжнародним асоціаціям
е-е позашкіл вдячні іншим цей колдовим
який постійно практично кроками нам
кажуть От дивіться оці моделі прийнятні
Ці моделі Ці моделі Їх потрібно
внести законодавство зробити певні
підзаконні
нормативно-правові акти зробити певні
речі у нас є з ними про те що я казав це
національний патріотично виховання це це
оновлення змісту
освіти що стосується виховної роботи як
і в стандартах Освіти загальної
середньої так і в програмах в
позашкільних закладах тому ми цю роботу
давно розпочали і ми її не кидаємо і цю
роботу ми доведемо до кінця
16 серпня колеги Верховна Рада України
прийняла за основу ще один проект закону
він називається
закон про утвердження український
національний та громадянський
ідентичності
багато з тих хто тут несуть брали участь
в розробці цього закону
проект закону як на мене добрий гарний
представляє по місцям багато речей а
саме головне що в цьому проекті закону з
якими ви можете ознайомитись на сайті
Верховної Ради він
закладає фундамент
потужної роботи
по
національно-патичному виховання так цей
закон покладає на систему освіти багато
зобов'язань
глибоких викликів але ми це Маємо
зробити і відверто кажучись давно
повинні були зробити виділяючи виховній
роботі
більше уваги ніж Можливо навіть і
освітньому процесі Можливо хтось мене
тому що
вихована дитина вона найкраща вчить
вчиться дитина з цінностями розумінням
хто є ми
самого ідентифікацією з маленького що я
україночка і я українець маленький це
основа
якісний
української європейської освіти
Шановні колеги з-поміж тим що існують
зміни в законодавстві і ми будемо
приділяти цьому глибоку увагу і ви
знаєте от ви маєте і нову концепцію
фактично виховання Я дуже вдячний
пановій Андрій всім авторам які глибоко
долучилися в короткий терміни розробило
щоб показати
напрям нашим регіонам по роботі щоб
чітко зрозуміти яким чином
необхідно рухатись Тим паче в такий
складний час
існує дуже багато практичних питань
сьогодення щогодини
І що хвилини практично це і як зміст
позашкільної освіти так і гурткова
робота і все інше Так ми розуміємо що
моделі Зараз трошки змінюються під час
це підказують але
необхідність оновлення змісту також дуже
важко що показали війна що показало
перед масове переселення дітей
внутрішньо переміщення і які здобувають
у них зовсім інші підходи інші
компетентності багато програм
позашкільних закладів не цікавить вони
не йдуть вони не йдуть
тому оновлення
змісту оновлення напрямків є дуже
важливим і рецепт дуже простий А давайте
ми запитаємо
що вони хочуть
не будемо думати самі собі придумувати О
давайте там комп'ютер чи там стем чи
щось інше робота з батьками опитування
батьків щодо
можливих компетентностей щодо
можливого
результатів знань щоб вони хотіли
досягти це дуже важливо
тому я Можливо трошки анонсую ми з
найближчим часом із
нашим партнером з юнісеф будемо
проводити
Можливо в пілотних областях дослідження
і серед батьків і серед педагогів щодо
оновлення змісту щодо оновлення
напрямків бо ми маємо і ви це чітко
знаєте надавати дітям сучасником
надавати сучасні знання які б їм
допомагали в практичному житті які б він
допомагали здобувати освіту
які їх підводили до профорієнтації і
підводили до легко до вищої школи
тут дуже важливо зараз це зрозуміти
тому що коли не цікаво
діти не йдуть в заклад А батьки їх не
ведуть
що далі відбувається і це все пов'язані
речі це я про ті запити з багатьох
областей
і ті що ми намагаємося
зберегти це закриття чи організації чи
справи профілювання закладів
позашкільної освіти ви знаєте яка в нас
біда зараз з мережею є
ради які закривають закони чому
це якраз про те що я казав коли
засновник не бачить що цікаво дітям туди
йти Він приймає непопулярне рішення так
мотивами для цих рішення Можуть бути
різні
школьні не
школьніцентралізацією Як правило це
пов'язано з тим
Міністерство освіти і науки і особисто
Сергія Миколайовича шкалік нашого
міністра дуже чітка позиція щодо
збереження мережі позашкільних закладів
тому ми постійно на всіх рівнях на
самому президента України і на рівні
областей постійно говоримо про
недопустимість закриття закладів а от
Друзі пітимете будь ласка міністр
підтримуйте будь ласка нас тим що ці
заклади мають бути наповним
новим духом новим повітрям
живими компетентностями цікавістю
різноманіттям форм здобуття
я саме звертаюся з таким коханням я
більше ж переконаний що ви нас не
підведете тим паче відкрилися ворота в
Європу шинку дуже багато
новацій
Європи діліться ви досвідом бо вам є що
показати але черпайте досить звіт
залучайте більше своїх ресурсів закладів
в заклади загальної середньої освіти де
зараз дуже багато дітей особливо
західних областях проводите гудки на їх
закладах на базі їх свої це дуже важливо
тому що мобільність і різноманіття форм
саме дасть вам
розуміння дитини
і розуміння роботи з дитиною і групою
дітей і спільне бачите що далі
Шановні колеги я
щиро хочу подякувати усім вам і кожному
з вас за ту потужну
цікаву
професійну роботу які ви проводите я
упевнений в тому що
вже завтра вже післязавтра
наше позашкілля почне рухатись більшими
темпами маючи мобільність можливості ми
зі свого боку лише будемо підтримувати
вас в цьому максимально мотивувати
воювати з усіма іншими нашими колегами
не воювати переконувати в
дофінансуванні позашкілля можливо
відкриті окремий субвенції
щодо співфінансування щодо проектної
діяльності Ми зробимо все для того щоб у
вас ці крила який є дали можливість
злетіти злетіти всій українській освіті
найякісний Новий рівень
ми вже вас Бог кожну вашої родини нехай
це розшифська гидота
покине нашу країну А краще і нашу
планету
бо таким цінностям тут не місце
я бажаю вам
хай буде вас все добре у ваших родинах
був достаток і ми
Слава Україні
Слава українським позашкільникам Віктор
Васильович все для 100% 200% підтримуємо
дійсно наше позашкілля дійсно ми
пишаємося нашими позашкільниками Дякуємо
за такі дуже-дуже
компетентні коментарі
нагадую на тому що в кінці цієї панелі
якщо будуть запитання то ми їх
обов'язково озвучувати наших спікерів І
я хотів би запросити до
слова також включитися в нашу розмову і
ще одного з наших спікерів А пан Роман
гладковський головний спеціаліст відділу
змісту освіти мовної політики та освіти
національних меншин директорату
дошкільної шкільної позашкільної та
інклюзивної освіти пана Романа ви з нами
так я з вами добре мене чутно
чудово пане Романе вітаємо вас аудиторія
чекає Добрий день шановні учасники
всеукраїнської серпневої педагогічної
науково-практичної конференції
позашкілля
2022 патріотизм із безпека Мені дуже
приємно вас вітати у на цьому заході і
звернути вашу увагу що
позашкільні заклади освіти це один із
тих елементів
освіти які доповнюють усі решту ланки
освіти починаючи від дошкільної
закінчуючи вищою перед вищою та освітою
дорослих Ну і зокрема включаючи повну
загальну середню освіту
у своїй доповіді перш за все хотів би
звернути увагу формування ідентичності
тема
аспекти
національно-патріотичного виховання як
військово-патріотичний виховання з за
своїми посадовими обов'язками я
відповідаю за такий важливий в останній
в останні роки предмет як захист України
в закладах загальної середньої освіти та
відповідно
військово-патріотичне виховання в
закладах освіти хотілося б зазначити що
сучасна ситуація в Україні сучасний
воєнний стан
зробив кардинальні зміни щодо підходів
щодо викладання навчального предмету
захисту країни в закладах освіти і
зокрема військова патріотичного
виховання особливо складову хочу сказати
в цьому процесі відіграло те що агресія
нарешті відкрила очі багатьом людям що
предмет захист України - це один із
основних і
має вивчатися на досить пристойному і
належному рівні що можна сказати до 2014
року було не дуже реалізовано у змісті
нашої освіти Також хотів би зазначити що
спочатку війни що 13-го року і спочатку
в гарячою фази 24 лютого
2022 року ми кардинально поміняли нашу
програму з даного предмету для закладів
загальної середньої освіти Тобто було
три рази
змінювалась сама програма змінювався
назва предмету Як ви всі знаєте до 20-го
року він називався захист вітчизни тепер
уточнено що саме захисту України і
відповідно
кардинально була змінена рік тому
програма а також за результатами
військової агресії ми в цьому році також
досить
точку але також досить суттєво змінили
навчальну програму з предмету захисту
України вона вже розміщена на сайті
Міністерства затверджена наказом від
03.08.22 року номер 698 і саме чому я
звертаю вашу увагу на це тому що
заклади позашкільної освіти мають
можливість перш за все під час своїх
позашкільних позакласних гурткових
заходів
розкривати ті чи інші теми з цієї
програми захисту країни яка передбачена
для вивчення в закладах загальної
середньої освіти Ну що хотілося б
зазначити які основні зміни що там
відбулися перш за все ми звернули увагу
на цивільний захист Ми всі знаємо що
війна
зробила ці речі які ну раніше ми і наші
діти знали тільки в теорії це перш за
все цивільний захист як поводитися в
екстремальних ситуаціях як поводитися чи
під час військової воєнної тривоги під
час обстрілів під час бомбардувань
поведінка дитини має вже закладатися
перш за все на уроках в школі це такі
уроки як основи здоров'я безпека
життєдіяльності в деяких закладах
професійної та фахової передвищої освіти
а також на уроках предмету захисту
України Ну що хотілося б сказати що
предмет реалізується перш за все
на виконання низки законодавчих актів це
перш за все закон України про військову
службу і військових обов'язок де
передбачена до призовна підготовка яка
включається до стандарту повної
загальної середньої освіти і
реалізується через тут два таких аспекти
викладання предмету захисту країни в
закладах загальної середньої освіти
професійної освіти та фахової передвищої
освіти а також Через заходи
військово-патріотичного виховання це
саме в через Заходи які реалізують
заклади позашкільної освіти і відповідно
на ваші заклади покладено саме
цей аспект зокрема через позашкільну
роботу щоб багато робиться саме в
центрах національно-патріотичного
виховання адже відповідно до стратегії
національного патріотичного виховання
військово-патріотичне виховання є його
складовою і через гурткову роботу через
різні
освітні заходи через
вшанування пам'яті перш за все
історичної пам'яті про наших героїв це
через Заходи які проводяться в закладах
освіти саме на це має набути направлена
Робота як в закладах загальної середньої
освіти так і позашкільної освіти Також
хотів би зазначити що
зміни які внесли до цієї програми
стосується деяких аспектів перш за все
історії українського війська Тобто ми
детально
не можемо на предметі захисту України
так як історії саме історію походження
оцієї російської агресії проти України
але основні аспекти
російсько-української війни вчитель
предмету захисту країни а також керівник
гуртка мають розглядати і
вмотивовувати перш за все громадян
України що щоб вони були готові перш за
все
жертвувати і захищати свою землю де вони
народилися де вони проживають і за яку
мають відстоюватися в будь-якій
точці земної кулі Інше питання що
цивільний захист також велику роль Ми
там майже цілий розділ присвятили в
програмі цивільному захисту це перш за
все особиста безпека друге питання - це
протимінна безпека яка дуже важливою
зараз є ви всі знаєте що третина
території України забруднена
вибухонебезпечними предметами і саме На
мою думку що кожен педагогічний
працівник який працює в закладі освіти
України зараз має обов'язково пройти ну
під час підвищення своєї кваліфікації
курси змінної небезпеки та поводження з
вибухонебезпечними предметами з якими
особливо на тих територіях дійшли бойові
дії ми всі бачимо Київщина забруднена
частково багато забруднений східні
регіони України і тому вчитель перш за
все має донести до дітей через власні
власний досвід власне навчання через
освітній процес оці знання як поводитися
з такими предметами і саме на це ми в
програмі захист України звертаємо увагу
в програмі з основ здоров'я звернули
увагу велике також значення має
поняття
віртуального простору і також ми
зацепили ту тему побіжно в нашій
програмі і також звернули увагу про
кібербезпеку про безпеку не тільки
фізичну фізичну а і віртуальному світі
тому питання кіберзахисту кібербезпеки
кіберпростору так як наші діти проводять
багато часу в цьому за комп'ютером і
кіберпросторі питання
кібербезпеки з захисту інформації
протидії фейкам і неправдивою
інформацією стає досить важливим і саме
заклади позашкільної освіти Ми також у
своїй роботі використовувати
ці прийоми щоб ознайомити учням
позашкільних закладів освіти стіни
знаннями також внесено було в деякі
точкові зміни в програмі щодо
до медпроведення тактичної та вогневої
підготовки
також картографічна підготовка
[музика]
дещо
скорегованість що дає можливість також
закладам позашкільної освіти так як в
них досить велика мережа закладів саме
туристично-краєзнавчої роботи
за заходів з військового патріотичного
спрямування саме на місцевості це дасть
можливість закріпити всі всі ці
теоретичні матеріали які в програмі на
практичних навичках і
застосувати їх потім в реальному житті
тут же хотілося б зазначити що саме
на заклади позашкільної освіти є
надія і покладання того що вони
дадуть можливість учням реалізувати всі
ці знання навички що вони набули Під час
вивчення предмету захисту україни-школі
відповідно потім під час проведення
військово-польових зборів чи занять а
також військово-польових
[музика]
польових Ігор таких як наприклад Сокіл
Джура яка вже показала своє свою
ефективність і досить популярної зараз в
Україні серед учнівської молоді і її
проведення
потребує багато ресурсу багато ресурсу
як від міністерств різних молодь спорту
зараз долучати треба і Міністерство
ветеранів і міністерство інформаційної
політики для задля того щоб проведена
цієї гри було б перш за все дієвим
досить цікавим і щоб учні перш за все
могли реалізовувати всі основи
програми основи законодавства там і
закону Про основи національного спротиву
і про і порядку Про підготовки населення
до Національного спротиву Який Ось був
буквально затверджено в минулому році і
на реалізацію якого у спрямовані усі
заходи щодо військово-патріотичного
виховання в закладах освіти тому хотів
би усім учасникам конференції перш за
все побажати міцного здоров'я в цей час
побажати успіхів на цій нелегкій нерві
розпочати організовано цей непростий
воєнний навчальний рік який буде щоб
ваші заклади також
процвітали так би мовити як казали
Віктор Васильович щоб вони давали ці
знання і навички тільки їм не дали
загальноосвітні навчальні заклади
професійні заклади дошкільні навчальні
заклади А ви розвивали перш за все
особистість дитини особистість учня
особистість громадянина який здатний
перш за все любити свою батьківщину
стояти на сторожі цієї батьківщини Ну і
продовжувати усі ці традиції які
продовжують наші військові коли
почалася мобілізація при всіх там
нюансах цього процесу але багато все ж
таки дітей людей молодих учнів студентів
потім
дорослих людей які вже були за кордоном
повернулися Я маю на увазі осіб
чоловічої статі повернулися щоб стати в
Бій із захищати нашу Україну і кожен на
своєму місці який зараз працює має
докласти максимум зусиль щоб перш за все
підтримати тих людей які зараз на
передовій захищають там багато досить і
освітян і позашкільників і вчителів і
мені б хотілося їм побажати удачі і
здоров'я перш за все і міцного
українського духу яким вони показують і
яким ми можемо пишатися тому Дякую вам
всім за увагу якщо будуть питання щодо
на освітньої програми Я з радістю
відповім
в кінці дискусії Дякую за увагу Слава
Україні і слава всім вам дякую
дякуємо дякуємо вам пане Романе Отже
Шановні колеги чи є в нас питання до
наших спікерів На жаль
пан сальков
терміново на наступну іншу локацію а
викликаний тому він нас зараз не зможе
долучитися от але в нас є пан Роман в
нас є пан Андрій якщо є аудиторії
запитання то будь ласка можна задати
нашим спікерам
Я думаю що настільки
конкретна настільки якісна інформація
спирання на законодавчі акти
пояснення фахові достатньо показують
рівень готовності до наших викликів під
час
початку нового навчального року тому ми
рухаємось далі І я
з величезним задоволенням зараз надаю
етер матеріалу від нашого гостя
віце-президента мережевої громадської
організації міжнародної академії гео
інформатики кандидати технічних наук
Івану Вікторовичу галенко будь ласка
відео
Вітаю пані і панове звернення
і Олега Винника за надану можливість
взяти участь в дискусії щодо реалізації
пріоритетів національно-патріотичного
виховання під час війни в закладах
позашкільної освіти і запропонувати
підходи які реалізовані як протестовані
команду основній грі кіберзуран
перш ніж викласти суть пропозиції хочу
звернути увагу на пост Нестора волі Як
гарантовано втратити підрозділ шкідливі
поради або інструкція недового командира
восьми пункт цієї інструкції звучить так
і беруть технології солдатам вони не
потрібні в них є лопатою автомат Навіть
якщо це розвідники такі нехитрі поради
якщо вісім допомагають стати командиру
поганим і максимально збільшити втрати
підрозділу
тобто вчителям втратити своїх дітей
як зменшити втрати на полі бою ми
обговорювали під час наради в РНБО 6
липня де були озвучені основні принципи
підходи кіберзулі реалізовані дні
окреслена актуальність згідно ви зможете
ознайомитися на блокпості кіберзура
ми ж перейдемо безпосередньо до самого
плану провадження технологій в цьому
році перше треба зробити це підключитися
до всесвітньої програми креслення з
модернізації шкільної середньої освіти
кожна школа можна безкоштовно отримати
доступ до хмарної технології але якісь
онлайн більше того з минулого року
американська компанія Естель дозволила
використовувати цей сорт для управління
закладом освіти або козакілля він
навчального плану до кадрової задачі і
логістики продуктів харчування
один з додатків всі технології - це
Stories всі технології ви бачите як дві
дівчинки 6 клас без допомоги вчителя
тобто виховника
створили сайт Лесі Українки і життєвий
шлях від народження до останніх днів
Тобто фактично і технологія яка
використовується для управління
військами на марші зокрема британської
армією дівчатка створили життєвий шлях
Лесі Українки
кожен курінь згідно 845 постанови
повинен бути імені героя когось
і давайте порівняємося сайти які
створили де
НВП державний центр
національно-патичного виховання про
Осипова Твардовського і два
десятикласника
ми бачимо
дошки простий текст який не сильно
відрізняється сайт провід Вікіпедія да
актуально так джерела там 5-67 А давайте
подивимося що ж ви робили два
десятикласника без знання мого
програмування це ніж людський ліцей
Просто протвердевство ви бачите на карті
аудіо відео
текстову інформацію і ви бачите картку
яка масштабується і карту фактично вся
земля куля від місця народження
Твардовського до Франції і інших країн
де вшановано його пам'яті
освоюючи ці технології Діти зможуть
перейти взяти участь в команда кіберзура
і це основний мозок нашої підготовки які
дозволяють забезпечувати мінімальний
рівень знань солдата для участі в
майбутнє участі у війні
під час модельної гри
кіберзура крути в НБУ ми показали
продемонстрували всі етапи цієї гри вони
включаються етапи перше - це створення
пантеону героїв забутих обрізаних
спотворених
очищення від брехні спотворення
історичних подій і створення
інвестиційного процесу території
діти 10-класники створили туристичний
маршрут по музею Героїв Крут за третій
пункт це є медцентричний і практична
війна і місце дітей в ній адже
невід'ємною частиною до призовної
підготовки чеської молоді окрім
національно-патичного виховання
формування оборони свідомості є
професійна підготовка у галузі сучасних
інформаційно-комунікативних технологій
команда штабна гра кіберзура це знання
про рівня автоматизованого управління
військами і силами
сюди включається безпілотні літальні
апарати
функціонування структури електронних
документообігу
інформаційно-відвідкова підсистема яка
включає всі види озброєння які існують в
світі
це створення електронних карт
це система координат НАТО
відображенням практичної обстановки
виміряна карті відображення шарів
електронної карти робота з рельєфом
місцевості прокладання маршрутів по
найвищій найнижчій точкам місцевості
оцінювань природних бар'єрних рубежів
різні розрахункові задачі в тому числі
розрахунок максимум без цих всіх знань
сьогоднішня участь в війні фактично є
приречені на смерть для того щоб
реалізувати команда штучну кіберзура Ми
плануємо наступні заходи ну один із
відкладених 24 лютого
- це
інтегрований урок предмету основи
правознавства де ми хотіли показати
зв'язок між конституцією і Україною і
хмарними технологіями Я думаю як тільки
обстановка Запорізької області
покращиться ми Цей урок проведемо
другий етап - це формування мережі до
призовних підготовки молоді на базі
сучасної навчальної
тобто у нас уже більше трьох десятків
команд Джурків більше 10 з них взяли
активну участь в минулому місяці
кібербезпеки і я думаю що в цьому році
ми продовжимо цю роботу ми відкриваємо
новий напрямок екологічного діяльності в
умовах мережі античних і практичної воїн
для того щоб показати зв'язок між
біорізноманітним і крупнокаліберними
снарями і основні заходи які відбудуться
вперше з них 14 жовтня до Дня захисників
і захисників Це український кіберпростір
презентація між проектів хмарних
технологій командних кіборів та
Середньої на тему життєвий шлях
історичних постати України для участі в
ньому треба сформувати гурток або
команду жорсткіборгів це може бути
опорно-штурмова команда якщо закладу
освіти має доступ до ліцензії і може
бути мережева команда якщо у закладах
освіти немає ліцензії і тоді інші
заклади освіти допомагають твердий
досвід і дають доступ до технології
за результатами цієї презентації Ми
повинні провести в грудні до Дня
збройних сил конкурс інтегрованих уроків
хмарних технологій серед команд на тему
облаштування
всесвітньоукраїнського кіберпосту
повторюся ці заходи плануються в рамках
місяця кібербезпеки 2020 які
підтримуються всіма фаховими
інституціями в Україні від РНБО до всіх
служб збройних сил
і головний етап який ми повинні пройти в
цьому році це почати формувати класи
кіборг кібержура
кіборг - це акронім
які складаються з двох груп комп'ютерів
по шість робочих місць і робочого місця
викладача з заходу колективного
відображення за допомогою цих
комп'ютерних класів Ми повинні
відпрацювати механізми
взаємодії або забезпечення підрозділу
морально спілкуються забезпечення Тайсон
налагоди взаємодію з кафедрами
загально-тактичної підготовки у вищих
військових навчальних закладів
почати освоювати прикладні задачі
інтернету речей і
почати співпрацю з кафедрими історії та
військового мистецтва відповідно робота
проводиться
з найближчим часом у нас уже повинно
бути два класи і вже готуються
обладнання для передачі другого класу
перший клас - це наші піонери Львівський
ліцей Героїв Крут який якраз і
запропонували цю модель класу
кіборг і розробили технічні вимоги до
оформлення цього класу і програми
забезпечення класи з'єднуються між собою
в мережу
через сервер
Славутич національного центру оборону
України
підсумовуючи доповідь про коротко Хочу
звернути вашу увагу що нові технології -
Це селекція війна - це теж селекція межу
визначає не куля а відповідальність куля
- це крапка Для жертв
безвідповідальності відповідальність це
життя чи він виграє вчитель ген
інформаційних систем бо інформаційні
системи - це історія і географія з
математики це інтегровані уроки - Це
нова реальність це просторовий аналіз це
те що потрібно для управління таким
популярними зараз хаммерсами
нептунамі
м 777 за іншими зразками сучасної
українського та іноземного виробництва
Дякую за увагу і до зустрічі на
платформі кібер-жура
всесвітнього проекту модернізації освіти
так студія студія А
дуже-дуже-дуже Дякуємо вам Вікторовичу
знову ж таки станом на сьогодні
враховуючи ситуацію враховуючи війну в
Україні враховуючи
інструментарій які пропонують учасники
нашої конференції враховуючи досвід
знову ж таки підкреслюю є цікаві є дієві
а форми і методи роботи і є
інструментарій які можна користуватись
тому я дуже дякую нашим а спікерам нашим
гостям які пропонують різні види а
можливостей для того аби наші діти аби
наші вихованці були Скажімо так
забезпечені можливостями бо станом на
сьогодні можливості для реалізації
е-е своїх задумів своїх цілей вони якраз
і потребують різноманітних
інструментарів і таким чином коли є з
чого вибирати то тоді звичайно і
КПД буде вищий тому Дякуємо Івану
Вікторовичу і я з величезним
задоволенням хочу передати слово
кандидат у педагогічних наук в старшому
науковому співробітнику провідному
науковому співробітку лабораторії
позашкільної освіти інституту проблем
виховання Національної академії
педагогічних наук України
пані Анна Корнієнко оце якраз один з
прикладів
практику-орієнтованого інструментарію це
приклад продукту про який пані Анна Буде
нам розповідати які розроблений і яким
можна користуватися тому пані Анна вам
такого будь ласка і ваша презентація
Доброго дня шановні колеги
Дозвольте вам вас ознайомити з
результатом роботи лабораторії
позашкільної освіти а саме це наскрізна
навчальна програма і метод рекомендації
які розроблені відповідно до змісту цієї
програми що ж передувало розробці даного
продукту Звісно це
анкетування яке проходило в Google формі
метою якого було виявити проблеми з
якими стикаються педагогічні працівники
і можливості і по можливості надати
матеріали на вирішення цих проблем
одним із запитань було
чи ви вносили корективи у зміст
навчальної програми ми бачимо що майже
75% опитаних дали позитивну відповідь
тобто вони вносили корективи у зміст
своєї навчальної програми
наступник було питання на уточнення які
корективи було внесено у навчальну
програму
бачимо що 15%
сказали що було скорочення годин
39% зміна змісту занять і більшість
розширення тематики занять
наступним питанням було які на вашу
думку навички ми маємо надати вихованцям
для їхньої безпеки наступних
більшість дало відповідь навички
безпечної поведінки надзвичайних
ситуацій
навички поводження з небезпечними
предметами навички першої медичної
допомоги навички корекції емоційного
стану і навички самооборони
наступним питанням яку методичну
інформацію ви шукаєте
на полі інтернету сьогодні
більшість дало відповідь методичні
рекомендації розробки занять готову до
впровадження
навчальні програми або іншу продукцію
недостатньо інформації щодо організації
роботи
позашкілля в умовах воєнного стану
відсутність розроблених готових до
впровадження педагогічних технологій
відповіді об'єднується змістом того що
вихованцям необхідно надати навички
безпечної поведінки в надзвичайних
ситуаціях але при цьому виділяється
бажання мати щось готове для
впровадження у практичну діяльність тому
співробітники лабораторії позашкільної
освіти завідуючий лабораторії
мачульський Валерій Віталійович
Корнієнко Анна Володимирівна провідний
співробітник і співавтори
[музика]
Вербицький Володимир Валентинович
директор закладу який нас сьогодні
приймає
національного екологічного центру
створили такий продукт як як наскрізну
навчальну програму з позашкільної освіти
основи безпеки життєдіяльності в умовах
бойових дій і також ми тут рекомендації
до них де можна ознайомитися
наступний слайд
наступний
так на
сайті Міністерства освіти і науки
України ви бачите зараз заставку на яку
можна орієнтуватися можна скачувати цю
продукцію вона в доступі трошки пізніше
я вона дам адресу і ще на інших
де розміщене продукція інші електронні
адреси
наступне
матеріали будуть корисними педагогічними
працівниками закладів позашкільної
освіти які організовують роботу для
різних категорій учнівської молоді зараз
ви бачите мету наскрізної навчальної
програми і завдання насрізної навчальної
програми
наступним
зараз демонструється
навчально-тематичний план наскрізної
навчальної програми ми бачимо що
програма розрахована на 18 годин
може бути реалізоване на заняттях
гуртків усіх напрямів позашкільної
освіти відповідно до цього вона може
бути використана в повному обсязі або за
окремими темами для посилання основної
навчальної програми відповідно до
напряму
які ж теми основні можна виділити цій
програмі Це умови війни правила та
поради хімічно небезпека
радіаційна аварія
рани та їх обробка пов'язки правила їх
накладання перша допомога при опіках
перегріванні обмороженні тест на
виявлення ознак життя
звісно тими темами не можна обмежуватися
щоб в повній мірі надати навички
безпечної поведінки в надзвичайних
ситуаціях але це не це та необхідна
основа до якої ви на свій розсуд можете
додавати матеріали
наступний
Тепер ви бачите демонстрацію слайда
зміст метод рекомендацій і ми можемо
помітити помітити що він повністю
розкриває теми навчально-тематичного
плану наскрізної програми
наступний
Дозвольте вас ознайомити системою
викладу матеріалу в метод рекомендаціях
От наприклад тема умови війни правила та
поради що ж ми там викладаємо Що робити
під час повітряної тривоги як поводитися
під час бо після обстрілу вдома на
відкритій місцевості в транспорті
правила поведінки під час комендантської
години що робити якщо Потрапили під
завал будинку види вибухових пристроїв
ви бачите що всі матеріали текстовий
матеріал він супроводжується або
картинками або схемами або фото ви
можете на свій розсуд розширювати
і схеми і картинки зараз Інтернет
простір дозволяється робити
наступне
Зараз ми бачимо картинки які
супроводжують теми пов'язки правила їх
накладання перша допомога при опіках
перегріванні і обмороженні наступні
матеріали метод рекомендації як я казала
повністю відповідають заявленим
завданням І це дає можливість досягти
прогнозованого результату
що ж буде в результаті вихованці мають
знати правила поводження під час
повітряної тривоги обстрілів
комендантської години правила погодження
при хімічній небезпеці тести на
виявлення ознак життя вміти впоратися зі
стресом під час війни накладати пов'язки
на різні частини тіла і набути досвід
накладання пов'язок на ті ж різні
частини тіла наступне слайд Зараз ми
бачимо
адреси де можна зустріти скачати звідки
нашими тут рекомендації і програми Це
офіційний сайт Міністерство
телеграм-канал Facebook Міністерства
також Facebook інституту проблем
виховання і сторінка лабораторії
позашкільної освіти Будь ласка заходьте
на нашу сторінку
запитання якщо є залишайте
бажано залишати також запитанням свій
номер телефону для того щоб ми могли
відгукнутися і дати відповіді або на
зауваження якісь реагувати які будуть
після того як ви будете впроваджувати
практично свою діяльність
навчально програму і методичні
рекомендації на цьому Дозвольте
завершити всього найкращого Дякую за
увагу
Анна Володимирівна ми вам також дякуємо
тому
продовжувати Будемо далі нашу
конференцію хочу одразу зазначити що
виступом пані Анни Корнієнко кандидати
педагогічних наук старшого наукового
співробітника провідного науково
співробітника лабораторії позашкільної
освіти інституту проблем виховання
Національної академії педагогічних наук
України ми завершуємо першу панель першу
панель нашої сьогоднішньої локації і я
вам хочу сказати що
назва взагалі нашої конференції
патріотизми безпека в першій панелі вона
розкривалася на 100%. і про патріотизм
йшла мова Про Національну патріотичного
виховання і про безпеку які продукти на
сьогоднішній день є розроблені і ну і ще
багато-багато різних прикладів на жаль
регламент не дозволяє нам поширено
поглиблено
розглянути цю тему далі але Це нам
здається що той матеріал який був
викладений в першій панелі він теж
потребує достатньої обробки обговорень
зрозуміння І тому ми рухаємось далі
наша друга панель друга панель нашої
конференції має назву
патріоти свого фронту це панель яка
представляє у нас саме ось той
патріотичний настрій нашого фронту
фронту позашкільників нашої діяльності
тут в тилу на окупованих територіях
за кордоном Тобто там де є зараз
позашкілля є просто вражений просто від
тих
перемовин які я вів от починаючи з 24
числа з керівниками закладів
позашкільної освіти з керівниками
гуртків тому тому що були величезні
неосяжні плани ті які ми готували всі
разом на завершення навчального року до
дня захисту дітей були плани на літо але
кляті недоліки вони просто от вкрали в
нас все те що Ми планували і тому
довелося терміново підлаштовуватись і
саме
позашкільники на лінії свого фронту
працюють потужно працюють не покладаючи
рук і нам дуже приємно що в цій панелі
беруть участь
наші гості наші партнери спів автор
проєкту діалоги про війну та фахівець
державного підприємства центр захисту
національного простору України що
знаходиться у сфері управління
Міністерства освіти міністерства
культури та інформаційної політики
України пан Володимир жемчугов
перед тим як він
пане Володимиру ви з нами ви фатері
Доброго дня Ви мене чуєте
Чудово прекрасно чуємо вас зараз ми вас
побачимо ви нам там підказуєте ваше
відео коли потрібно показати от ми
готові продемонструвати на загал Ну
давайте
Доброго дня всім Я Давайте почнемо з
кратко
відеоролика який ми підготували для
презентації нашого проекту будь ласка
відео
[музика]
чому так потемніло наше місто наступила
хмара
Ой а я вас парасолька А навіщо тобі
парасолька бо ж якщо я знайшла хмара то
буде дощ Ні це хмара війни
що тепер будуть стріляти так будуть
стріляти буде страшно бо кожна війна це
жорстокість насилля біль і сльози і на
війні бувають людей
[музика]
Отже пане Володимиру вам слово
досить Зрозуміло такий натяк трошки
невеличка технічна проблема показала
только один епізод тих всього там три Ну
ладно то я додам усі повний матеріали і
ми можемо їх подивитись пізніше Я
представник міністерства культури
інформаційної політики і ми почали
створювати цей проект
діалоги про війну ще робота ним в 2020
році
кратко розкажу чому чому мета возникла
стала по створенню цього проекту з 2018
року Міністерства інформаційної політики
я займався
проектами національно-патріотичного
виховання в закладах вищої освіти Ми
зробили декілька проектів і такі як
братці Кремля або як починалася війна
зняли фільми по ці проекти і
їздили в відрядження по усім регіонам
України в обласний центр в регіональні
транслювали короткі
[музика]
коротенька інформація цих фільмах і
спілкувалися з
учнями вищих учебних закладів і завжди
коли я приїжджав Ну і будь-який обласний
центр чи місце я знаходився не тільки з
деканами знаходився і просив познайомити
мене з
ну
з преподавателем який займався виховною
роботою я завжди питав про план виховної
роботи національного патріотичне
виховання
просив показати на сайті останню подію
національно-патрічного виховання або на
Фейсбуці або в Ютубі цього навчального
закладу і дуже часто були проблеми з цим
коли я Звертався до
цих педагогів я запитував чому Так чому
ви Ну і підготовлений чому немає такої
роботи не вистачає такої роботи мені
казали що у них не завжди завжди була
одне та слова вибачаєте у нас нема
металічної документації у нас нема
методички оце слово в нас нема методички
я чув усі три роки вже
18-19-20 роки до пандемії Ми об'їхали
більше 60 закладів вищої освіти в деяких
обласних центрах у нас Департамент
освіти Департаменту інформаційної
політики просили відвідати заклади ну
профтехучилища або середньої школи і ми
давали такі лекції і в транслювали
фільми дарували книжки і в деяких школах
і ну в простих училищах і ну усюди були
питання що у нас нема методичної
вивчаєте у нас не вистачає методичної
документації коли я звертався що Ну вже
там там п'ятий рік іде війна є інтернет
вчителі мені казали що з цим дуже багато
проблем ми
пробували скачувати
матеріали із Інтернету аби але там були
такі е-е суть ну випадки що в матеріалах
ну раптом використовувалась карта
України без Криму або без Донбасу або
замість матеріалів про
захисників наших військових в
антитерористичної операції там чомусь
опинялися відеоматеріали з
російсько-чеченської війни або взагалі
інформація про якусь там Велику
Вітчизняну війну ну у нас ну мне
зверталися до мене вчителя що ну не
вистачає
нормативної документації
дуже шкода що
ну була сказано дуже шкода що
національно-політичне виховання тим Ну
не курсів нема в державний програми
освіти є тільки там в 11 класі захист
України і все але ми розуміємо що дітей
треба вчити з перших класів я сам
слуганщини і я пам'ятаю
14-15 роки коли прийшли росіяни Вони
почали у дитячому садочку починати
кожний день з гімна Росії з першого
класу починали уроки
військово-патріотичного виховання сразу
давали дітям з першого класу в руки
автомат вчили як йому користуватись
деяких класах з 10 років
на Луганщині в місті Ровеньки вони
створили росіяни створили диверсійну
школу і вчать там дітей українців наших
е-е ну диверсійному Ділу ви можете
подивитися це єсть дуже багато відео в
Ютубі
зараз іде гібридна війна і ми розуміємо
що гібридної війни
перемагають не генерали на полі бою а
перемагають вчителя історії і Росія це
знає І вона це використовує от на цих
цих регіонах схід України
південь України де Росія
підміняє поняття ну в деяких випадках
бреше відкрита розповідає Що це землі
якоїсь Новоросії щодо екатерини взагалі
там нічого не було ніякої ні українців
там не було нічого там не було а-а і
Катерина прийшла і принесла цивілізацію
на Схід і на південь України
сьогоднішній - це Ну це взагалі жах
тому вот появилась такая думка створити
таку інформаційний проект в допомогу
вчителям ще Ну как бы и така друга
мотивація ви знаєте Ну не для вони не
секрет что на сході на півдні України
там їй Ну дуже багато проживає
проросійського населення дуже багато
всього населення являються вчителями ви
бачили і в 14-му році І зараз от це на
окупація і повномасштабної що
ну
відносно процентному відносно
процентному ставленні дуже велика
частина вчителів перейшли на стали
корабле колаборантами і даже стали
пропагандистами Русского Мира Я не кажу
про тих вчителів які просто працюють
виконують там роботу в чат дітей ті які
стали просто пропагандистами Це просто
жах і цей матеріал ми розробляли
Міністерства інформаційної політики
розробляли разом з інститутом
національної пам'яті ми розробили
методичні
документацію так щоби любої вчитель или
в северодонецьку или в Одесі или в
Херсоні
в Маріуполі даже в Луганську мог взяти
ці матеріал і там була все прописано від
Доброго дня До побачення і не мог
ставити туди ні інше Ну ніякого слова
про якусь там громадянську війну чи про
рахунку чи про Вітчизняну війну там Ну
все було прав сплановано так щоби
вчитель на почав урок
сказав по подводку ми под каждый урок
зняли такий 50хвилинний
відеоролик щоб дітям було цікаво
дивитися Ми там використовували акторів
от дівчинку от і до 10-річну
ми
попробували ці уроки в Київській 309
школі ми побачили що да коли е-е каже
Вчитель це не так цікаво Але когда
дитина бачить на екрані і таку ж дитину
як вона сама це його зацікавлює діти
були дуже уважно слухали цю дівчину і
його питання
відповіді дівчині давали
е-е дійсні ветерани сьогоднішньої війни
і були такі питання перше урок тема
цього року що таке війна чому не можуть
порозумітися хлопці які в класі Почему
починаються бійки Почему дорослі люди не
можуть порозумітися що таке війна трошки
з греческая міфології щоб ну людям дітям
було дуже ну цікаво і зрозуміло другий
урок - це
чому уже більше 300 років Росія нападає
на Україну в Росії змінюється Влада
змінюється правители але чомусь все одно
Росія воює з Україною і третій урок
сучасна війна як війна почалась в 2014
році як це відбувалася і як війна йде
зараз
Ми
зрозуміли
документацію методичну там дається
можливість вчителю на у вибір зробити
там три сценарія як спланувати свою
уроку можете учитель вибрати який ми
буде ну цікавіше дітям буде такий план
зробити щоб донести цю інформацію дітям
щоб була взагалі дуже просто вчителю
вести ці уроки ми ще
зняли додатковий фільм назвали його як в
школі дітям розповідати про війну ми як
вам казав 309-й школі в Києві зробили
такі пілотний проекти вчитель давав
перші уроки цієї дітьми реальним дітям і
ми знімали на відео цей процес потім ми
зробили нарезки самих цікавих моментів і
зробили 45 хвилинний фільм Ми теж його
вам додаємо використання де ви можете
подивитися вот як конкретний вчитель
давав ці приклади і давав цю інформацію
дітям
Відповіді дітей як они регулювали на
ці запитання ці там конкурси які
проводились і ну це дасть можливість
вчителям Ну даже не знаю там далекому
селі будем так Вибачайте за мною просто
тут далекому селі не дуже професійному
вчителю подивитися
цей матеріал почитати ці методички і
зробити ці уроки в своїй школі я являюсь
дійсно мучаю ну ветеранам АТО і я
представляю суспільства ветеранів АТО
які от активні харизматичні які
намагаються щось зробити сьогодні і
питаються Достучаться до молоді ми
розуміємо якщо ми втратимо дітей ми
втратимо Україну
сьогоднішні солдати
повинна знати за що вони воюють що це їх
земля це їх Історія
ця мотивація приходить з дитинства з
дитинства те що ви так Як виховували їх
в школі і ми даємо дуже побажали щоб нас
допускали не только позашкільне
виховання а й в державній програмі якщо
б вони були національно та патріотичного
виховання в школах це дуже важлива щас
іде війна і ми знаємо історію цих типу
ще 300 літньої війни України з Росією ми
Я впевнений що це не остання війна поки
у нас буде кордон спільний з Росією ну
яка вона не була де був щоб вона
розвалилась і появи з'явилася тут інші
якісь держави на кордоні з Україною а
Росія повернулася в свої історичні
кордони Московської області Але поки
цього не сталося я война може бути і
інша і буду продовжуватися війни Росія
така держава ви бачите свою історію Вона
створила тільки на захопленні сусідніх
держав
Вибачайте За моїми аналіз
Дякую за увагу якщо будуть питання Я вам
дуже Радою
Дякуємо пане Володимире тому що
насправді ваша емоційність абсолютно
зрозуміла в кожного з цих хто зараз
дивиться нашу конференцію теж є
емоційність внутрішня і кожна свідома
українська душа вона не може без емоцій
сприймати і ситуацію яка зараз
відбувається і ті
особливості дій які можуть бути на
місцях зроблені і позашкільниками і
взагалі нашою освітянської спільнотою і
тому емоційність вона якраз є та частина
нашого фахового життя бо я не ну я я
і всі інші Мої колеги вони зрозуміють що
позашкілля не може бути без емоційним в
нас закладена емоція і це правдива
емоція це щира емоція тому наша
емоційність вона потре це місце бути Ми
дякуємо вам за потужну доповідь От і
продовжуємо нашу панель друга панель
патріоти свого фронту знову ж таки з
приводу емоційності починає емоційності
а питання да дійсно воно особисто і
кожного з нас є свої Скажімо так
особливі моменти емоції але я вам скажу
так
не схоже на інші емоції в мене виникла
Коли я побачив те відео яке підготували
наші колеги з
центру туризму тому що зараз ми хочемо
запропонувати вашій увазі ось той
яскравий приклад коли
і викладачі і випускники зараз
знаходячись на передовій вони абсолютно
успішно використовують ті навички ті
знання які вони отримали в мирний ще час
відвідуючи гуртки відвідуючи заклади
позашкільної освіти навчаючись сам
певним речам які зараз рятують життя
Тому я прошу зараз звернути увагу на
відео яке підготовлено нашими колегами з
туристичного центру Отже будь ласка
прошу відео
Дмитрович
старший лейтенант збройних сил на
сьогоднішній момент в минулому або в
цивільному
майстер спорту зі спортивного туризму
керівник гуртків івано-франківського
обласного державного центру туризму і
краєзнавства працюю з дітьми з
2008-1998 року дуже багато моїх
вихованців на сьогоднішній момент
служать Збройних Силах
отримали досить великі навички спортивну
туризму яким завжди згодилася в житті Ну
і я надіюся зараз допоможуть їм
прес-служби в Збройних Силах тому
необхідність збереження такого
сектору позашкільного її роботи як
туризм Я дуже важливим оскільки туризм
допомагає
дітям і мені в тому числі Також він дуже
сильно допоміг вижити в дуже складних
умовах тобто дає навички орієнтуватися
до не дає навички виживати швидко
приймати рішення тому підтримую
пропозицію щодо збереження позашкільної
осві Всім привіт Мене звати шкапа Анна
Ігорівна Мені 18 років Я проживаю в
місті Києві Наразі я знаходжуся в
Збройних силах України
41-му батальйоні патріот також Окрім
цього Я випускник Українського
Державного центру з пішохідного туризму
протягом двох років Я очолювала команду
Українського Державного центру Також ми
дворазові чемпіони України
і наразі Окрім роботи в батальйоні окрім
виїздів на передову Я маю змогу навчити
військових як правильно працювати з
серединою як правильно відпрацювати в
Мостиському як правильно орієнтуватися
та як правильно зв'язати вузли бо на
передовій це і справді дуже-дуже важливо
це і справді рятує життя бо ти не знаєш
яка може бути ситуація а вони там
бувають дуже різні
пішохідний туризм дуже в цьому може
допомогти Всім привіт мене звати Ігор я
є працівник Кіровоградської обласного
центру туризму 24 лютого я перебуваю в
складі збройних сил України зважаючи на
сьогодення реалії хотілось би зазначити
на важливості позашкільної освіти а саме
труска спортивного напрямку в даний час
для кожного з нас дуже важливо знати Та
й вміти орієнтуватися на місцевості
вміти надати першу долікарської допомоги
вміти зав'язати з підручних елементів
носі для транспортування потерпілого
вміти виживати в екстремальних умовах
всі ці знання Ви отримаєте на гуртках на
заняттях
зі спортивного туризму тому
записуйтесь на гудки
Бережіть себе Слава Україні
Героям слава позашкільникам Слава і ось
такі приклади Вони реально надихають і
таких прикладів сотні таких прикладів
тисячі і ми пишаємося і нашими
випускниками і нашими викладачами ми
пишаємося всіма тими хто
незважаючи на обставини зараз своїми
особистими зусиллями наближає нашу
перемогу фраза яку всі ми не просто чули
не просто відчули а фраза з якою ми
живемо з Надією фраза яка звучить
по-чесному і вірно у кожного зараз свій
фронт вона
підкреслює що наші внески
перемогу яку Так ми чекаємо Вони
знаходяться поруч з нами і ми щоденно
щохвинно робимо на своєму місці все те
що
здійснить нашу спільну мрію тому
величезна вдячність щирий
чистосерденний такий уклін тим нашим
викладачам випускникам
вихованцям батькам вихованців
керівникам закладів
всі спільноті яка це розуміє і яка
свідомо робить все для того аби це світо
день скоріше постав
кажучи про спільноту взагалі
позашкільників
величезну кількість прикладів про те як
же ж наші позашкілля А за кордоном
створює Ось такі знаєте осередки
української культури осередки
української ідентичності і
просто Сльози нагортаються на очах коли
ми бачимо Що що Який відгук знаходять
Наші діти наші позашкільники Та й
взагалі наче освітяни за кордоном
у нас є друзі наші Грузії в Тбілісі які
Скажімо так долучилися до нашої
конференції
надіслали нам спеціальне відео я хочу
представити вашій увазі виступ директора
національного палацу молоді міста
Тбілісі
тільки рухадзе і ось вашій увазі її її
виступ її розповідь будь ласка
аудіо
формули Education from
airganycle darti School for Ukrainian
chilter
activities
and educational
Space Edition
Ukraine
Generation
and
First Earth of independents No mattery
Continuous working Forever
Це була Тіка рукадзе тільки рухадзе
директор Національного палацу молоді
міста Тбілісі
я ж кажу чисельна кількість відео на
Ютубі на
Instagram Facebook про те що
в закордонні наші
партнери про свідомі просто іноземці як
вони підтримують Україну як вони
підтримують наших дітей наших освітян за
кордоном Це просто ну шалена кількість і
шалена прихильності
це цей Це це є досягненням і визнанням
нашої з вами роботи Шановні колеги тому
честь нам Хвала
Я продовжую нашу конференцію і Оголошую
наступну панель панель номер 3 кращі
практики за 175 днів війни і
в цьому блоці я задоволенням хочу надати
зараз слово
директору Кіровоградської обласного
центру дитячої та юнацької творчості
керівнику Кіровоградської обласного
відділення державної академії
позашкільної освіти заслуженому
працівником освіти України депутаткові
Кіровоградської обласної ради пані
павлівні суркові
мала Павловна будь ласка
до етеру Я знаю що ви нас бачите чуєте
якби
прошу Шановні колеги
Центр дитячої та юнацької творчості
презентує вам власний досвід своєї
роботи під час війни якщо викласти його
в декількох фразах то він вкладається в
зміст цитати скульптової книги Сонь
дзинь Мистецтво війни
постійно розвивайся ніхто не дивиться на
минулі досягнення і трофеїв важливо
тільки тут і зараз тому потрібно
постійно зростати професійно і
особистісно інакше неодмінно прийде за
стіл наступні у нас будуть такі
запитання наш заклад вбачав у
оперативній мобілізації позашкілля
області на роботу в умовах воєнного
стану першим випробуванням наших
можливостей здатності мобілізації
творчої та небайдужої освітянської
спільноти навколо ідеї незалежно від
обставин організувати роботу
станолановитими дітьми України став 27
всеукраїнський фестиваль дитячої та
юнацької творчості присвя всесвітньому
дню землі Які ми провели незважаючи на
дуже складний період в житті нашої
держави і хоча тематика фестивалю була
побудована за концепцією земля для нас
та наших нащадків цілі сталого розвитку
путівник людства ціль 11 розвиток міст
та спільнот ми
відредагували зміст онлайн туру виходячи
з Реальної ситуації в країні наприклад
онлайн-квест передбачав низку завдань
про шляхи відбудови країн світу після
Другої світової війни спілкування в
онлайн форматі учасників номінації
громадська думка з експертами щодо
можливих шляхів відбудови нашої країни і
хоча географія кількість учасників була
значно менше ніж зазвичай в цьому році
вона склала 2000 учасників з дев'яти
областей України сам факт того що у
березні ми підтвердили на всю Україну
про його проведення а український
державний центр позашкільної освіти
підтримав нашу пропозицію про пан
ренесення термінів збору заявок
фестивалю був сигналом
позашкільникам що Життя продовжується а
Україна не здається
враховуючи відношення України з
європейськими країнами під час
російсько-української війни ми повністю
змінили зміст умов всеукраїнського
фестивалю європейсьст 2022 визначивши
його тему Європа наш спільний дім
спільне сьогодення спільні цінності
спільне майбутнє учасниками цьогорічного
фестивалю стали представники 716 дитячі
колективів з 19 областей України а також
вимушені переселенці які тимчасово
проживають у Німеччині Латвії Польщі
Швеції Австрії Нідерландах Португалії
Словакії Фінляндії Болгарії та Туреччини
Загалом у конкурсній програмі фестивалю
взяли участь понад 2000 вихованців які
представили на розсуд журі свої творчі
роботи У конкурсах відео-поезій постерів
світлин коміксів та мемімів учасники
євроклубів парламенті в дітей змагалися
у номінації квіз країнами Європи який
включав участь у низці конкурсів під час
яких обговорювали допомогу європейських
країн в Україні під час
російсько-української війни
демонстрували Власне бачення спільного
європейського майбутнього України у
Європейському Союзі за ініціативи голови
кіровоградського обласного осередку
всеукраїнської громадської організації
народної академія творчості інвалідів
Ельміри небесної кіровоградським
обласним центром дитячо-юнацької
творчості спільно з українським
державним центром позашкільної освіти
департаментом освіти і науки
Кіровоградської обласної військової
адміністрації міжнародної асоціацію
позашкільної освіти молодіжної
громадської організації центр був
проведений всеукраїнський творчий
інклюзивний фестиваль натхнення без
кордонів у заочних та онлайн-фарматах в
ра різних заходів до Міжнародного дня
захисту дітей 1 червня фестиваль був
проведений з метою соціалізації дітей та
молоді з інвалідністю засобами мистецтва
побудови безбар'єрного суспільства
реалізації стандартних правил
забезпечення рівних можливостей цього у
фестивалі взяли участь понад 500
учасників з 15 областей України
Враховуючи те що кіровоградщина стала
прихистком для понад 150 тисяч вимушених
переселенців більше половина з яких діти
нашим закладом разом із однодумцями і
Сполучених Штатів Америки було
започатковано міжнародний проект
психолого-соціальної допомоги Велла Ми
не можемо змінити напрям вітру але ж
завжди маємо змогу підняти вітрила аби
досягти мети Саме ці слова оскару
Уайльда характеризують мету та завдання
проекту який створено спільно з
університетом Леслі
бачите травми кембріджу масачусетс
Сполучені Штати Америки з метою надання
психологічної допомоги та підтримки
людям що опинилися у психотравмуючих
ситуаціях внаслідок воєнних дій
підтримки фахівців та обміну досвіду
спеціалісти з інституту травми Леслі
травма інститут надавали необхідні
знання та підтримку психологам і
педагогічним працівникам для
профілактики емоційного виснаження
відновлення внутрішнього балансу в
рамках проекту було організовано
зустрічі практичних психологів педагогів
мистецькі галузі вчителів корекційної
роботи фахівцями Департаменту інклюзії
колеги поділилися досвідом роботи з
дітьми що мають особливі освітні потреби
були представлені відеофрагменти
корупційних розвивальних заходів проєкт
об'єднав педагогів та психологів
Кіровоградщини та Донеччини зі
спеціалістами штату масачусетс чотири
рази на тиждень проводяться різноманітні
навчання проект набирає обертів
збільшується коло партнерів Ви також
можете долучатись до нього Влітку ми
розпочали співпрацю із представництвом
юнісеф в Україні через партнерів
слов'янські культурний центр Задзеркалля
у питаннях психолога соціальної
підтримки дітей та молоді це також дуже
цікавий досвід яким вартує скористатись
Шановні колеги від нам на жаль
продовжується в цих умовах на педагогів
покладається особлива місія готувати
наших дітей до майбутнього життя бо за
висловом французького письменника та
політичного діяча Луї арагона вчити
значить всіляти надію і саме це є метою
практик які сьогодні презентувала
Дякуємо Дякуємо На Павлівна дуже потужно
дуже-дуже знаєте так багатогранно і я
вам скажу що таких прикладів в нас в
Україні
дуже-дуже багато тому дуже вам дякую
прошу зараз до слова
Сергія Анатолійовича пугакова заступника
директора комунального закладу
Кіровоградської обласний центр туризму
краєзнавства та екскурсія Чернігівської
молоді та директор Луганської обласного
центру дитячо-юненського туризму
краєзнавства Тетяна Василівна а Всі ми
знаємо Шановні колеги Що
клята війна змусила наші наших колег
зриватися своїх місць тому що домівок
нема розбиті міста розбиті заклади
позашкільної освіти розбиті заклади
освіти
страшно страшенні просто втрати і
довелося
виїжджати зі сходу двом нашим центром і
знаходити прихисток в
кіровоградському обласному центру
туризму краєзнавства та екскурсію
учнівської молоді тому ось якраз ось
прокоментувати цю ситуацію взагалі
розказати про свій досвід про те що ви
такого там робите разом про
ті відчуття що у вас на серце на душі
будь ласка зараз от з усіма нашими
колегами з усіма про дошкільниками вона
загалом широкий будь ласка вам слово
Сергій Анатолійович Тетяна Василівна
прошу Доброго дня колеги Вітаю всіх
да дійсно склалася ситуація спочатку
війни на кіровоградщину як уже
повідомила напал на перебу були змушені
переселитись близько 150 мешканців
територію охоплених бойовими діями
зокрема на Кіровоградщині прибули два
центри туризму це Луганська і донецький
На жаль сьогодні керівник
Донецького центру туризму перебуває у
відрядженні не може до нас приєднатися
але все ж таки Нам вдалося спільними
зусиллями враховуючи досвід роботи і
потенціал в цих трьох колективів
влаштувати
розмістити ці наші заклади помістити на
нашій території на сьогодні більш-менш
вирішено питання з помешканнями
працівників донецько-луганського центру
а також Ми розмістили працівники
приміщення як нашого закладу і спільними
зусиллями намагаємося побудувати і вже є
певний досвід роботи з молоді це перед
усіми діти є батьки яких мають статус
внутрішньо переміщених осіб і зокрема і
місцевими нашими мешканцями і
Кіровоградщини зокрема під час
населення липня в серпня місяця Нам
вдалося в рамках обласного проекту літо
2022 Разом до перемоги організувати на
території нашого центру такий проект як
літня школа туризму де працівники як
кіровоградського центру туризму так і
працівники луганського Донецького центру
яке долучились до цієї великої акції
мали змогу спільно працювати надавати
знання з спортивного орієнтування
велотуризму пішохідного туризму та
краєзнавства молоді Яка до нас активно
долучалася
зокрема досвід
тренерів і керівників гуртків з
велосипедного туризму краєзнавства
Донецького луганського центру був нам
досить таки доречний тому що фахівці за
деякими напрямками нашого центру Назара
це перебувають в лавах Збройних Сил
України на сьогодні ми будуємо
перспективні плани в подальшому зокрема
наші колеги вже оголосили колеги з
донецького центру туризму спільного з
українським державним центром
національно-патріотичного виховання
краєзнавство туризму учнівського молоді
певний проект - це всеукраїнського
конференцію яку вони організовують уже
тепер перебуваючи в нас в мати надію що
вона відбудеться Ну і є великі задумки і
проекти в нашій колег які вони хочуть
реалізовувати як очно в нас
безпосередньо на Кіровоградщині так і
дистанційно з дітьми які є їхніми
безпосередніми вихованцями в Луганській
Донецькій області тому якраз директора
луганського центру
Василівна підготувала певну інформацію
яку можна з вами поділитися передаю її
слово
Добрий день шановні колеги дуже рада
бути присутньою на нашому зібранні І
дійсно досвід у нас поділитися досвідом
на жаль не дуже таким трохи печальним
будемо казати тому що двічі вже наш
заклад покидає територію наш свого своїх
приміщень і цього разу ми знайшли
прихисток на Кіровоградщині дуже вдячні
нашим колегам
спочатку вирішувались питання
організаційні і без їхньої допомоги
деякі питання були дійсно складно нам
вирішити але потім ми розпочали роботу і
роботу деякі проекти були спільні я не
буду повторюватися як Сергій
Анатолійович сказав а от деякі проекти
ми почали працювати уже як в
дистанційному форматі як і працювали
Багато наших закладів освіти нічого
нового в цьому Ми не можемо не можемо
сказати єдине що було це дуже складно
було організувати роботу гуртків тому що
розпалися заклади освіти розділилися
роз’їхалися діти розділилися роз’їхалися
викладачі але все одно завдяки тому що
змінилася програма плану роботи нашого
Українського Державного центру
національно-патріотичного виховання
краєзнавства туризму ми підключилися до
цієї роботи і за ці майже півроку вже
деякі брали участь в деяких заходах і
даже діти наші діти були призерами і
переможцями Всеукраїнських заходів тому
я хочу сказати що
дякуючи підтримці всіх наших колег і
дякуючи тому що наше позашкілля все ж
таки не розгубилася і знайшли в собі
педагоги сили і свої знання застосувати
Ми продовжуємо працювати сподіваємося на
нашу перемогу і сподіваємося на
повернення додому і бажаю вам всім також
сил Терпіння і всього доброго і Перемоги
Дякую за увагу
дякуємо дякуємо Тетяна Василівну Дякуємо
Сергію Анатолійовичу а насправді ось це
є тим
Яскравим прикладом
взаємодопомоги саме
між
колегами тому що
незважаючи на обставини незважаючи на
ситуацію от за кілька днів
Але це дні для нас бо вони прилітають
дуже швидко розпочнеться навчальний рік
розпочнеться
навчання розпочнеться освітній процес і
всі ми позашкільники
дуже-дуже-дуже сильно і щільно
взаємодіємо саме з
загальноосвітніми закладами тому що від
графіка роботи загальноосвітніх закладів
формується графік роботи закладів
товщиною освіти і ось ці наші взаємодії
наша взаємодопомога значить
взаєморозуміння воно є тією головне з
складовою майбутнього успіху я недаремно
показував на самому початку нашої
конференції а-а картинку з слайду який я
встиг да зняти на м-м пленарному
засіданні відкриття конференції з
виступу нашого міністра Сергій
Миколайовича де було представлено просто
чотири моделі отримання
адаптації та на місцях
наших вихованців Тому треба буде з цим
скористатися обов'язково в фіналі нашої
конференції ще раз покажу цей слайд тому
що це
дуже-дуже-дуже конкретизує наші дії на
місцях і величезним задоволенням Я
продовжую нашу
нашу конференцію конференцію позашкілля
2022 патріотизм безпека і ми переходимо
до
наступного нашого учасника третьої
панелі Олег Степанович Бондарчук
завідувач відділом національного
педагогічного виховання
декілька слів знову ж таки кажу
регламент
максимум 5 хвилин дуже прошу вкластися
щодо важливого процесу прикладу да
важливого процесу приклад оздоровлення
дитячого оздоровлення в таборі
Турійського активу в Закарпатті та про
діяльність літніх шкіл туризму тому будь
ласка Олег Степанович що ви бачили вже в
ветері получаєтесь до нас вітаємо
Вітаю всіх колеги
не буду вказувати місце свого
перебування і запитань безпеки але
трішки про наш табір філія Українського
Державного центру туризної краєзнавства
учнівської молоді
державного центру
національно-патріотичного виховання
територія табору була відома для
туристів дуже давно ще в той час коли
тут була
середня школа і
ми на слугувала базовим центром для
туристів України які із території школи
пройшовши деяку адаптацію акліматизацію
виходили цікаве походи по українських
Карпатах
Потім після побудови нової школи
на території
села було цей будівля старої школи була
передана українському державному центру
для організації туристського табору і
зараз це філія Українського Державного
центру національно-патріотичного
виховання
табір туристського активу центральний
табір туристського активу учнів України
Якщо раніше стартували наші туристи і з
території табору і табір десь
відвідували до 5 тисяч туристів які
виходили в різноманітні походи дуже
цікаві місця вулканічні Карпати
Зачарована Долина
чорна багнова інші походи
то
після того як
було зменшено фінансування табір почав
проводити оздоровчі зміни і різні
всеукраїнські масові заходи це і
конференції і злити і семінари і
[музика]
збори переможців різних краєзнавчих
експедицій краєзнавчий зльоти
і
Всеукраїнська дитяча юнацька військова
патріотична гра Джура двічі проходили на
території табору в 2010 та 12-му році а
надалі працювали школа
активу школа ройових школа для самих
маленьких Ми почали залучати найменшого
вікову групу
від 6 років до роботи до збору до
українських території почала працювати
школа Котигорошко на території табору
табір веде активну оздоровчу роботу і
активну є такою базою методичною базою
для відпрацювання програм і спортивного
туризму з краєзнавства з
національно-патріотичного виховання і
теж на жаль час війни в ній свої
корективи у роботу табору спочатку
виміри у таборі
як переселенців було більше двох з
половиною тисяч осіб перебували на
території табору не тільки дорослих а
і дітей і я скажу що силами
колективу і колективу Іршавського району
було зроблено велику роботу і діти не
просто перебували на території табору
пересиджували
страшний час Але були організовані
цікава робота навчання
активно задіяні були
з ними проводились заняття і спортивного
туризму вони вивчали краєзнавство
закарпатського Краю
Були задіяні в активну таку діяльність
Це
дало можливість і цим дітям і дорослим
полюбити цей чудовий сонячний край і
вони хочуть повертатися ще раз і ще раз
і на сьогоднішній день
ми знову повертаємось у табір і будемо
проводити на території нашого табору
заходи з національно-патріотичним
виховання і спортивного туризму Будемо
збирати переможці краєзнавчих експедицій
на території табору Це прекрасний чудове
місце місце знань місце навчання місце
змагань місце походів і
місце куди хочеться повертатися ще раз і
ще раз дякую колеги
Дякуємо Олег степановичу Дякуємо вам
всім вітання
вашому таборі всі журі І взагалі
реально вам скажу що недаремно кажуть що
є в нас в Україні міста сили місця сили
Звідки ми беремо енергію нашої
Української Землі і будемо робити цю
роботу далі
пані до панове Я задоволенням переходжу
до наступної сторінки нашої віртуальної
студії нашої локації позашкілля 20-22
безпека та патріотизм і ради представити
вам наступного нашого Скажімо так
категорії учасників це представники
державних центрів це якраз оті чотири
Острівця які
координують діяльність по багатьох
напрямах позашкільної освіти і мені
величезна приємно повідомити що на
Центральна студія сьогодні абсолютно
була б неможлива якби не допомога
національного екологічного центру
керівником якого є
Володимир Валентинович Вербицький і я
задоволенням хочу сказати що зараз в нас
в студії знаходяться і Володимир
Валентинович директор на центру і
Людмила Олександрівна цюнь завідочка від
його онкології центру тому будь ласка
вітання ваші нашим колегам прошу
колективу національного контуристичного
центру та колективів позашкільників
екологічного на профілю України з цією з
цим днем з колегією Це надзвичайно
величезний крок в сьогоднішній день для
того щоб ми ще раз і ще раз вірили і
побачили один одного в той тяжкий час
коли якраз наша праця потрібна найбільша
я перше за все хотів би присутності всіх
подякувати директорам працівникам
позашкілля які сьогодні захищають
Україну
в сьогодні вони являються героями
позашкілля тому що від них сьогодні
залежить і наше майбутнє з другої
сторони я безперечно дуже хотів би вас
попросити зрозуміти що сьогодні просто
історичний час
попри біль страждання Та розруху ми
все-таки мусимо створити не дуже
об'єктивні обставини для нового
навчального року і знову-таки по-іншому
по-новому показати позашкілля показати
його ефективну роботу в
національно-екологічному напрямку і
перше наше завдання - це педагогіка
виховні практичні та організаційні дії в
національно-патріотичному Русі Це
надзвичайно важливе питання надзвичайно
наукове тому що якраз педагогіки
педагогіки виховання ми можемо бачити
майбутнє наших школярів як би там нам не
було
сьогодні відомо всі педагогічні наукові
тексти або теорії Ми мусимо пам'ятати що
напрями виховання якими сьогодні
позашкілля мусить дуже жорстоку і чітко
зайнятися це громадянське виховання це
безумовне виховання це моральне
виховання це
екологічне виховання це статеве правове
трудове естетичне фізичне але все
залежить від освітнього процесу якщо в
нас цей освітній процес справді буде
направлений на виконання оцих напрямків
виховання в позашкіллі Повірте ми
переможні тобто педагогіку виховні
аспекти у нашої діяльності надзвичайно
потрібні але вони можуть бути практичні
та організаційно виправдані в дії
національно-патріотичного виховання
На жаль прийшов в той час коли ми мусимо
відійти відпустити слів
тому що війна
страшна війна і треба говорити про дівей
про дієвість наших сьогоднішніх дій і
заходів Я з великим би задоволенням
Сьогодні перелікував би все те що
позашкілля в тому числі як
колонтаїстичні центри зробили за період
не тільки 8 років попередніх війни але і
сьогодні і сьогодні в той час коли
надзвичайно важко і робота з
переселенцями і збирання всіх
можливостей і фінансових і продуктових
наборів для наших військових і
супроводження наших учнів які
знаходяться сьогодні на передовій лінії
Це надзвичайно велика дія і я би хотів
би сьогодні вам сказати що треба думати
і робити потрібно кожному на кожній
нашій ділянці роботи я завжди з великим
задоволенням міг би представити великий
проект нашої діяльності коли туристичних
центрів та власний позашкільників бо
сьогодні не можна говорити як окрема
система якого металістична ми з вами
дуже серйозно відповіли тренінги курси
підвищення кваліфікації педагогічних
працівників і кожному хто проходить Ці
тренінгові курси даємо право бути
тренером який може працювати в клубах
гуртках
супроводячи свої знання якраз
національно-патичний виховання і
сьогодні багато вже педагогів і навіть
військових які прийшли після фронту
мають ці документи тренінги тренінгів і
готові працювати школярами бо сьогодні
навчальний процес мусить розпочинатися
якраз з самого самої маленької дитинки
ми створили лігу тренерів і ліга
тренерів це вже досвідченіший тренер
який сьогодні говорять не тільки про те
що і як робити А це двігательнерів яка
дає право сьогодні нові освітній
платформі для національно-патичного
виховання ми
створили Академію виховання або
виховника де запрошуємо на курси
підвищення кваліфікації найкращих
педагогів-виховників тому що виховників
сьогодні це надзвичайно
людська педагогічна і
профільна робота людей не кожний
сьогодні може бути виховником багато ми
говоримо про виховання але виховник як
виховник з теоріями педагогічними
тактиками дуже сьогодні мало Ми
запрошуємо цих ендеміків виховної роботи
з усієї України особливо з педагогічних
вузів які ми могли би робити лекційні і
авторські програми по вихованню Ми дуже
хоті коли з вами говорити в майбутньому
про громадську організацію організації
патріот.ua це
еколого-патріотична гра паросток яка на
межі із роботою чугри
відправили створює свою
проекцію на навчально-виховний процес де
еколого-патритична града є право
Сьогодні дітям любити свою країну любити
свою землю любити свою квітку любити
свою маму любити свою маленьку
Батьківщину Я дуже далекий від того
щоби сьогодні повчати кожного з вас тому
що в нашій душі як говорили сьогодні
шановний один із директорів від серця і
мого і головного мозку і де імпульси до
захисту нашої країни
я єдине хотів би попросити що
ми мусимо сьогодні увійти в нову
парадигму
післявоєнної дії а може й сьогоднішнього
дня Це екологія військової діяльності
дуже багато проблем із екологічними
діями які нам створили маркул меркурти
манкурти бо я так називаю цих фашистів
манкурти і нам прийдеться створювати
нові вірніше створює наш відділи
екології нові програми екологія
військової діяльності де ми могли би
створювати всі обставини для того щоб
відновлювати екологію після війни
і останні слова я хотів вам говорити про
інтернет чи особист герої поруч який
запроваджений в нашому центрі і дуже б
хотіли що цей часопис
заповнювали думки бачення і розповіді
дітей і громад громадян які знають що
таке від учасників що таке війна і її
злість
найважливіша наша
проблема і питання - це можливість
збереження
позашкільних центрів в Україні Я вважаю
що на сьогоднішній день об'єднання
реорганізація зміна статутних
діяльностей наших позашкільних закладів
це
ворожіє ворожий кроки які нам не можна
допустити і всіх хто на цьому
життєвому процесі може впливати на
керівництво державних установ щоби
зберегти позашкільних заклади Це вже
буде надзвичайно велика наша перемога
тому що я в попередніх своїх виступах і
сьогодні повторюю що позашкільна освіта
Це найвища освіта вона надається дитині
сама маленького віку до самого старшого
віку Ну і забажаю вам як тест
сьогоднішньої нашої конференції це
любити вірити знати і коли ми будемо
любити свою Україну коли ми будемо
вірити наших бійців і наших дітей які
виховуємо ми а це надзвичайно важливо то
ми будемо вкладати пізнання які
найбільше потрібні для нашого
колективного
позашкільного розуму я звертаю вашу на
універсальність нашого і дуже хотів би
що ви це зрозуміли це слово
універсальність це ми можемо все
позашкільники можуть все і навчати і
виховувати і створювати і організовувати
ми універсальні педагогічній освіті і
звертаю вашу увагу на ту класичну
педагогічну освіту яку ми даємо сьогодні
в наших позашкільних закладах де є
статути і статути статутах чітко
написано є
проекти є профільні дії які ми мусимо
виконувати я звертаю вашу не насанови
витримку яку ми мусимо всіх громадяни
України тримати сьогодні бо несамовито
це витримка дасть нам право ви ж Бачите
як нам нашим бійцям важко але вони не
самилити витримані для того щоб в
принципі перемогти бо тільки витримки ми
можемо перемогти я звертаю вашу увагу на
дисципліну і класність нашу до перемоги
тільки дисципліна і класність наша
професійна надасть право майбутньому
поколінню утримувати нашу державу на
висоті цивілізованого розвитку Ось
бачите наскільки різниця розвиток країни
яка напала на нас і розвиток наших
українців які наскільки освічені
наскільки порядні що навіть можуть це
аналізувати і звертаю вашу на велику
консолідарність ми всі мусимо
концентруватися для того щоб витримати
цей страшний удар удар бажаю вам в
навчальному році бути такими якими ми
потрібні для нашої держави дякую дякую
Володимир валентиновичу Я прошу зараз
так щоб всі крім тих слів які ви сказали
ще і візитівку відео
національного екологічного центру
учнівської молоді Міністерства освіти
науки України Давайте давайте
переглянемо
[музика]
[оплески]
ось такий він національний
еколого-натуристичний центр учнівської
молоді цікавий дуже дуже
особливий дуже
різноманітний сучасний і насправді це
отак потужна хвиля екологічного
сприйняття світу екологічного виховання
і дотичності до справжнього життя оце от
На мою думку така знаєте особливість
цього нашого державного центру а Шановні
колеги задоволенням хочу надати слово
Людмилі олександрівніцюнь завідуючий
відділом екології на національного
колонацистичного центру з доповіддю на
тему еколого-патріотичне виховання
молоді як необхідна передумова створення
громадянського суспільства спираючись
саме на досвід ненсу Отже будь ласка
Людмила Олександрівна вам
Вітаю Шановні колеги
Дозвольте познайомити вас з досвідом
роботи національного контуралістичного
центру учнівської молоді Міністерство
освіти і науки України з
еколого-патріотичного виховання як
необхідної Передумови створення
громадянського суспільства
в умовах збройної агресії Росії проти
України
заклади позашкільної освіти
еколого-натуралістичного напряму які
наразі є потужним виховним середовищем
де формується особистість дитини
продовжують активно працювати для
розвитку творчих здібностей дітей молоді
забезпечуючих змістовне дозвілля та
психологічну підтримку і в цьому
контексті одним із пріоритетних напрямів
діяльності є національно патріотичне
виховання
національний колантерористичний центр на
державному рівні координує роботу 5000
394 творчих учнівських об'єднань
еколонтерористичного спрямування де
працюють понад
84.940 вихованців
Ненсі реалізує значущі проекти у сфері
патріотичного виховання здобувачів
освіти а саме
всеукраїнська еколого-патріотична гра
паросток яка формує у юнацтва готовність
до активної громадянської позиції та
екологічної діяльності
шанобливого ставлення до традиції
українського народу Ми пропонуємо вам
матеріали
еколого патріотичної гри паросток за
2021 рік в цьому році ми її будемо
проводити в жовтні місяці і
Я думаю що всі наші учасники минулорічні
обов'язково надішлють свої матеріали
всеукраїнський фестиваль патріотичних
дій Міжрегіональна комунікативність
підростаючого покоління як
найефективніша ланка роботи з метою
об'єднання дітей це чудовий захід
проводиться він а влітку Ми запрошуємо
дітей переможців наших конкурсів і
найактивніших учасників гри паросток
всеукраїнська
Всеукраїнський юнацький природоохоронний
рух Зелена естафета фестивалі скарбниця
народної духовності Україна сад
Всеукраїнський конкурс квітникарства та
ландшафтного дизайну Квітуча Україна
а також Всеукраїнський конкурс есе
патріотичного громадянської тематики
єднанням сильні До речі щодо цього
конкурсу хочу кілька слів сказати дещо
ширше ми його в цьому році провели
вперше і зазвичай Заходи які проводяться
вперше вони
не настільки мають потужний список
учасників а от якраз до цього конкурсу в
цьому році приєдналася величезна
кількість учасників причому роботи
цікаві роботи сильні і роботи
пронизані таким дійсним відчуттям любові
бажання допомогти своїй країні і бажання
окреслити показати Оте що вони побачили
в очах і наших захисників і того періоду
коли наші землі були звільнені від
ворога і якими Вони залишилися також
Всеукраїнський заочний конкурс робіт
юних фотоаматорів Моя країна - Україна і
знову ж таки вперше проводився
всеукраїнський Бліц конкурс ескізів
моралів все буде Україна це декілька
буквально декілька ось таких ескізів ми
підібрали які чудові роботи надійшли
важко навіть сказати і це все творчість
наших дітей не
віртуальний музей злочинів держави Росія
такий музей Ми створили для того щоб
показати все ж таки що натворили ось ці
злочинці в нашій країні
конкурс
конкурси флешмоби конференції навіть
значні урочистих дат української
державності а саме до дня незалежності
України дня соборності України дня
державного прапора дня Героїв Небесної
Сотні дні пам'яті та примирення для дня
захисника та захисниці України акція
подарунок воїну і багато інших щорічно
на базі всеукраїнської школи передового
досвіду Ненсі проводяться збір лідерів
Всеукраїнської дитячої спілки дитячої
екологічних парламент
збірнатівських секцій українського
товариства охорони природи хочу сказати
що національний контургістичний центр
реалізує значущі проекти у сфері
патріотичного виховання різних категорій
працівників освіти а саме тренінги з
національно-патріотичного виховання
дітей та молоді які проводяться з 2015
року разом із інститутом позашкільної
освіти Національної академії
педагогічних наук України що навчальний
форум всеукраїнської Ліги тренерів з
патріотичного виховання в рамках
фестивалю патріотичних дій патріот фест
спільно з комунальним закладом
позашкільної освіти обласний
контуристичний центр Житомирської
обласної ради Перепрошую Інститут
проблем виховання
виховання
інститут проблеми виховання академії
економічного
Перепрошую
школа-виховника всеукраїнського
виховного консорцю національного
контуралістичного центру та інституту
проблем виховання Національної академії
педагогічної Наук України також видання
віртуального часопису герої поряд корум
українських патріотичних справ Ми
українці та багато інших у
2022-23 навчальному році національний
еколонтерористичний центр запроваджує
нові освітні проекти зокрема кімната
мураді ненс розмір екопростір для дітей
навчальна програма довкілля війна та
інші війна обов'язково закінчиться
перемогою України
але
після перемоги перед нами постануть
жорстокі реалії наслідки бойових дій А
це і руйнування екосистем забруднення
грунтів хімічне забруднення від
обстрілів і ракет зменшення
біорізноманіття До речі у нас зараз
величезною проблемою стає проблема із
дельфінами які надзвичайно страждають
наші екологи повідомляють що в Чорному
морі гинуть дельфіни і це серйозна
проблема із сьогодні і вона буде в
майбутньому зростання кількості
шкідників у лісах наслідки від пожежна
промислової і сільськогосподарських
об'єктах і цей клас піднімати Нам усім
Дякую за увагу
дякуємо дякуємо Людмила Олександрівна
Дякуємо Володимир Валентинович а от
наступний
державний центр який я хотів би
представити центр Який теж має своє
Скажімо так своє свою місію А це
український державний центр позашкільної
освіти яким я представником якого
являюсь і я пишаюся тим що я працюю в
цьому центрі і хочу сказати що ось ці
два напрями які коригує наш центр це
художньо-естетичний напрям та
науково-технічний напрям це Якраз ті дві
стежини на яких саме реалізовуються мрії
наших дітей це Якраз ті можливості які
діти можуть реалізувати займа можливість
в гуртках по цих напрямах а тому для
того щоб Ну скажімо Так
більш деталізувати не хватить навіть і
трьох таких конференцій але в нас є
невеличкий промо яке Скажімо так зараз
на часі і крім того що ми не будемо
перераховувати ті заходи Які ми провели
за цей період за 175 днів війни А всі
прекрасно це етап знають і бачать там як
соцмережах і на сайтах і таке інше Але
найголовніше - це те
внутрішнє відчуття яке створюється у
наших дітей у наших батьків у наших
колег І взагалі всіх причетних до того
що ми з вами робимо на своєму місці тож
Прошу дайте нам нашу коротеньке відео
[музика]
страшна війна прийшла на нашу землю
здавалось
недотворчості всім нам
але малюнки наші і пісні і
вірші Це наша відповідь три клятим
ворогам
нас зсувуйте реоборонять
всі хто загинув хто герої назавжди
ми відбудуємо міста наші і села
розбійним лиш трішечки завжди
Надія Віра і любов до України щодня нам
сили додають повір
ми разом чи війну переживемо і в Україні
знову запанує мир
[музика]
Шановні колеги з нами на зв'язку
заступник директора Українського
Державного центру позашкільної освіти
Олена Василівна Федоренко Олена
Василівна вам надаємо
». так зовсім нещодавно навіть Важко
було уявити що зміст наших дітей будуть
звучати слова про війну і це на жаль
буде реальність у сьогодення Майже 6
місяців тому Перед кожним з нас постали
виклики Як жити далі працювати навчати
та виховувати наших діточок і вкотре ми
довели що заклади позашкільної освіти є
дійсно унікальними та неповторним станом
на сьогодні можна вже говорити про
потужну силу Про тил України силу
позашкілля завдяки мудрості таланту
витримці та нескінченному патріотизму
наші педагоги не лише зуміли продовжити
працювати з вихованцями закладів багато
установ стали прихистком для громадян
які На жаль вимушено залишили свої
домівки педагоги продовжили навчати
дітей
незалежно від їх місця перебування
заняття у гуртках стали сімейними тому
що багато дітей які разом зі своїми
батьками приходять на заняття для того
щоб через творчість через заняття
відновити свій емоційний стан і навіть в
таких умовах ми продовжили свою
діяльність і щодня працюємо для того щоб
кожна дитина де вона одне знаходилася в
якій країні світу продовжувала співати
танцювати малювати виготовляти моделі
кораблів та літаків тобто займатися
своєю улюбленою на звичною справою як і
було це ще до війни завдяки злагодженій
роботі та співпраці з психологічними
службами підготовлено цілий ряд
методичних рекомендацій про ті постійно
проводиться робота з волонтерськими
організаціями надається допомога
госпіталям військовим частинам та
загалом усім усім хто її потребує
постійно усі заходи всеукраїнського та
міжнародного рівнів адаптовані та
підготовлені з урахуванням можливості
дітей брати у них участь конкурси
фестивалі змагання змогли відбутися
завдяки консолідації нашої зусиль за
регіональними закладами позашкільної
освіти
художньо-естетичного та
науково-технічного напряму завдяки їх
талановитим керівникам та педагогам
спочатку війни твори у виконанні наших
дітей можна почути у багатьох країнах
світу завдяки започаткованому дитячому
онлайн радіо на YouTube каналі нашої
установи працює всеукраїнський відео хаб
де розміщується майстер-класи з
технічної творчості вокалу танцювальні
заняття інтелектуальні та розвиваючі
ігри проведено та розміщену серію
історичних майстер-класів культура та
побут Київської Русі розроблено цілу
рубрику цікавих занять кожен охочий має
змогу у вільний для себе час зупинятися
улюбленою справою завдяки педагогам
створено цикл серій по вивченню мали
ознайомих сторінок історії нашої
прекрасної України усі вони транслюються
на офіційному каналі нашої установи ми
спільними зусиллями навчилися
адаптуватися та швидко реагувати на
виклики сьогодення та продовжувати
працювати Не дивлячись на усі перепони
та складнощі усе це звичайно не могло
відбутися безлагодженої роботи закладів
усіх рівнів на жаль це перше літо дай
Бог щоб воно було останнім коли в
історії незалежної України позашкілля
працювала 24 години 7 днів на тиждень
без вихідних але завдяки мудрості та
правильному прийнятті рішень керівництва
закладів спільно ми змогли не лише
завершити розпочаті проекти а й успішно
започаткувати нові Незабаром у нас
розпочинається навчальний рік
ми звертаємося до місцевих адміністрацій
щоб у новому навчальному році кожна
установа мала підтримку та можливість
приховувати працювати з дітьми це наше
майбутнє і від нас сьогодні залежить
яким воно буде війна завершиться і
перемога беззаперечно Буде за нами і ми
повинні зберегти усі наші установи для
того щоб забезпечити право кожної дитини
на позашкільну освіту Ми залежимо також
від роботи закладів загальної середньої
освіти від їх графіків від їх можливості
працювати І дуже сподіваємося що наша
подольша робота буде успішною
продуктивною так З кожним днем
наближатиме нашу перемогу
хочеться особливо сьогодні висловити
слова щирої подяки та низькій уклін
педагогам усіх регіональних установ ви
не лише зуміли утримати механізм роботи
які був напрацьований десятиріччями але
продовжуєте навчати розвивати нашу дітей
їх творчі здібності і таланти наших
прекрасних красивих талановитих
неповторних юних українців Я бажаю усім
вам сил терпіння міцного міцного
здоров'я
перемога неодмінно Буде за нами Слава
Україні
Героям слава Олена Василівна Дякую вам
дійсно
все те що з нами зараз відбувається
це
випробування якого ніхто не очікував
Ніхто не знав але ми маємо вистояти
задля майбутнього
Я хотів би ще сказати два слова про
учасників нашої цієї сторінки а сторінки
досвіду державних центрів дошкільної
освіти і перейти до
центру також з особливим потужним
науковим потенціалом
Але перед тим як то відбудеться я прошу
показати спочатку відео тому що це відео
та відповіді на безліч запитань мала
академія
ми мали амбітні цілі та раділи кожній
перемозі ми розвивалися із мінотворили
але 6 місяців тому все довкола теж
змінилось
6 місяців великої війни боротьби за
цінності героїзму кожного українця і
кожної Українки 6 місяців переосмислення
заради тих хто творитиме нашу країну бо
Ми впевнені що освіта найпотужніша зброя
світу ми запустили оновлені сайт і
освітню науково digital-платформу тут
Про науку лише доказово цікаво і мовою
підлітків наші діти 10 разів піднімали
жовто-блакитний стяг на міжнародних
змаганнях 113А нагородами із знаннями
захищена Слава і честь України шість
місяців освіта долає межі разом із
центром науки Коперник запустили проєкт
досліджує науку українською тепер
українці в Польщі навчаються та пізнають
світ своєю рідною 6 місяців освіта єднає
українська молодь спілкується з
нобелівськими лауреатами про важливі
відкриття 40 науковців світового рівня
підтримали нас лекціями з весни понад 50
подій для дітей і пе відбувалося щотижня
в рамках нашої освітньої діяльності ми
вберегли експонати і відкрили
інтерактивний простір музею науки у
Львові ми запустили власний видавництво
дитячої та підліткової літератури і за
партнерилися з посольствами України в
Європі щоб маленькі українці мали доступ
до якісного україномовного контенту 6
місяців освіта дає надію ми організували
та провели наймасштабнішу інтелектуальну
Битву року в онлайн-форматі конкурс
захист Man Манівці захищали свої наукові
роботи в екстремальних умовах але
невпинною жагою до науки рекордна
кількість проєктів у фіналі
1568 ми провели 17 літніх шкіл 1338
учасників літнього навчання які звикли
розвиватися і прагнуть більшого Україна
першою в світі Отримала право проводити
національний етап олімпіади геніїв ми
провели національний відбір jinnius
олімпіад Ukraine та визначили переможців
вони представили Україну у США
міжнародному фіналі у Штатах Манівці
вибороли 51 нагороду Поліна Козлова
вперше в історії України отримали
найвищу нагороду в категорії креативне
письмо гран-прі
Україні and Future Business інкубатор
Man провів український регіональний
відбір до стартап World Cup понад 60
країн світу змагаються за головний приз
1 млн доларів інвестицій серед них і
Україна проєкт манна поїде у кремлієву
долину і змагатиметься за 1 млн доларів
шість місяців освіта прагне зберегти ми
провалився український конкурс сейв
спадок діти користувалися технологіями
де СЗ та позначили понад сотню
зруйнованих і пошкоджених пам'яток
культури
ці шість місяців ми продовжували мріяти
і діяти ман для всіх хто прагне більшого
далі буде і все буде Україна
Шановні колеги ось такий план Ось така
Мала академія наук ми пишаємося ми
пишаємося тим що ми бачимо знаємо
відчуваємо і робимо Я з величезним
задоволенням хочу надати етер Тетяні
вікторівні щирині заступнику директора
малої Академії Наук тягне Вікторівна
будь ласка
Доброго дня
шановні колеги
насамперед Я хочу передати вітання від
цена лісового директора національного
центру Мала академія наук України який
сьогодні на передовій який боронить який
сьогодні боронить нашу територіальну
цінність
цілісність який сьогодні
боронить наше майбутнє майбутнє наших
дітей Я хочу передати вітання від
президента малої Академії Наук України
Станіслава довго який сьогодні активно
займається
масштабуванням і створенням музеїв науки
наукових центрів в наших регіональних
відділеннях малої Академії Наук України
Я хочу передати вітання від
колективів обласних малих Академії наук
і територіальних відділень дійсно ці
шість місяців
стали для нас таким часом не тільки для
нас взагалі для освіти і для країни в
цілому стали для нас часом боротьби і
незламності і мабуть сьогодні на один
раз неодноразово піднімали питання про
важливість важливість нашої роботи
важливість позашкільної освіти і це
також стало часом усвідомлення нашої
роботи яку ми проводимо спільно
ми пишаємося і усвідомлюємо наскільки
креативні творчі талановиті наші молоді
науковці і це непрості слова оскільки ви
бачили відео що 113 міжнародних нагород
вибороли наші Манівці На серйозних
міжнародних інтелектуальних наукових
змагань
спільними зусиллями Міністерства освіти
і науки України
департаменті освіти і науки України
територіальними колективами
територіальних відділень національним
центром Нам вдалося зберегти і провести
найбільше інтелектуальне змагання яке є
на сьогодні в країні
Всеукраїнський конкурс захист малої
Академії Наук України і в цьому році
1568 учасників
1568 дітей мали можливість захистити
свої проекти презентувати свої
досягнення і цим ми маємо гордитися
гордитися має гордитися наша країна ми
маємо дякувати тим науковим керівникам і
педагогам які доклали максимум зусиль
для того щоб діти досягли таких
результатів для того щоб діти мали
можливість презентувати свої
напрацювання серед інших проектів малої
Академії Наук Які ми провели за час
війни і про які ми коротенько говорили
відео але хочу ще раз наголосити
зазначити підкреслити бо це оскільки це
підтримка
міжнародної освітянської спільноти це
лекції майбутнього відновилівських
лауреатів за честь війни відбулося 40
науково-популярних лекцій які мотивували
дітей до заняття науки
науковці підтримували морально
підтримували ділилися знаннями наших
знаннями з нашими учнями серед інших
проектів які варто зазначити
і які відбулися за ці шість тяжких
місяців це наші онлайн-курси
національний центр провів більше 50
онлайн курсів для дітей регіональна
регіональні відділення обласні малі
Академії Наук реалізували більше 200
проектів освітніх проектів для дітей які
були відкритими для всіх бажаючих варто
зазначити і роботу з
педагогами Це ті курси професійної
майстерності які пропонували наші
регіональні відділення які пропонував
національний центр і які об'єднали
навколо себе за ці шість місяців близько
двох з половиною тисяч педагогів
ще ми мали декілька
проектів які відбулися Вперше це
національний відбір до олімпіади
національний тур до міжнародної
олімпіади геніїв і це
ми встали першою країною яка мала такий
подібний досвід роботи наш бізнес
інкубатор провів теж національний відбір
до фінального етапу стартапу workup і
один проект буде презентуватись в
національному етапі конкурсу премії
видалили
ми за ці 6 місяців запустили новий сайт
малої Академії Наук ми зробили
відкрили
доступ до освітньої платформи і
наповнили її навчально-методичним
забезпеченням і
Закликаємо пропонуємо долучатися до тих
курсів до тих освітніх пропозицій які на
сьогодні є на нашій платформі цікаві
проекти
досліджує науки українською - це спільна
ми провели з польським центром
сучасності млин знань власне видавництво
нас запрацювала І це все завдяки
потужній роботі Як колективу
національного центру так і колективів
регіональних відділень малої Академії
Наук України
я хочу подякувати за ту величезну
титанічну роботу яку провів кожен із
позашкільників для того щоб ми своєчасно
і там де це можливо відновили освітній
процес Я хочу побажати побажати всім
насамперед здоров'я я хочу побажати
успішного нового навчального року і
мирного року насамперед і найшвидший
нашої Перемоги Дякую колеги за кожен та
увагу
Дякуємо Тетяна вікторівну Дякуємо вам
Дякуємо всім манівцям Хочу зазначити
колеги Що на підсумок нашої сторінки
досвід державних центрів
щойно ось в нас ветері були представлені
три центри але Нагадую що потужно про
свою роботу заявляв нам на самому
початку нашої конференції наша
центр
національно-патріотичного виховання на
чолі з Андрієм алісотою і Хочу зазначити
що
так дійсно у кожного свій фронт і
оксенсивий Геннадій шкура директори
державних центрів зараз на передовій
боронять нас від ворога і
Валентин Володимир Валентинович
Вербицький і Андрій Андрійович лісота у
себе тут на місцях проводять колосальну
роботу для для того щоб наші колеги на
передовій себе відчували впевнено а наші
діти і вихованці знали що новий
навчальний рік розпочнеться обов'язково
за різними формами але він розпочнеться
і їх
потенціал їх дитячі мрії вони будуть
Дійсно реалізовуватись я з величезним
задоволенням хочу надати зараз
РТР
нашим гостям гостям з національної
академії педагогічних наук України
доктору педагогічних наук професор
головному науковому співробітнику
лабораторії морального громадянської там
між культурного виховання інституту
проблем виховання Національної академії
педагогічних наук України Катерини
олександрівні журбі пані Катерино
дякую дякую
дороге освітяни
безправжні Герої які тримають свій фронт
і є ефективними у цьому перед вами хтось
дуже важлива задача це боротьба за нашу
Молодь не допустити витрати покоління
я вбачаю цьому кожного оце саме кожного
є свій фронт і перед нами цей фронт є
освітянський А перед вами це позашкілля
війна є
випробуванням тригеру для усвідомлення і
поступу нації Потім мобілізував усі наші
ресурси і допоміг усвідомити нам хто ми
є що ми є українцями Та відсікти усе
другорядне не тільки ми а й весь світ
побачив нас в іншому світлі Я хочу
сказати що не тільки батьки і політики і
громадські діячі а й зарубіжні політики
громадські діячі учені такі як сенси
спокуяма наголошують на тому що ця війна
і є війною саме за національну
ідентичність Так саме вважає і Путін
який проводить саме геноцид українського
народу і Наша задача
вистояти зберегти себе зберегти свою
ідентичність і в цьому плані Я хотіла би
вам сказати що саме 16 серпня 2022 року
буквально два дні тому назад було
прийнято у першому читанні законопроект
номер 6341 про основні засади політики у
сфері утвердження української
національної і громадянської
ідентичності а це означає що проблема і
питання націона соціальної ідентичності
і є надзвичайної державної ваги сучасних
умовах
Я також би хотіла сказати дещо і про наш
інститут бо мабуть більшість з вас
скільки зараз об'єдналася що взагалі
існує такий Інститут проблем виховання
чи не так
і це тут проводить дуже активну роботу в
цьому напрямку і не тільки з
національно-культурної ідентичності а й
національну патріотичного виховання
співробітники нашого інституту
наш директор інституту Іван Дмитрович
Бех
та інші є авторами концепції
патріотичного виховання української саме
українського патріотичного виховання
дітей та
дітей та молоді і така програма була
розроблена
ще з
2014-2015 році і вона досить була
розповсюдженою у школах і в закладах
цієї програми сьогодні колектив
інститут також програму нова українська
школа у поступі до цінностей
і в цій програмі дуже чітко Ця програма
за 19-й рік дуже чітко її можна знайти
її можна знайти в інтернеті можна знайти
в електронній бібліотеці Національної
академії педагогічних наук України в цій
програмі дуже чітко визначаються виклики
які стоять перед нами які стояли перед
нами і які є перед нами на сьогодні Які
декрифі є у зв'язку з цією війною яку ми
маємо в Україні і програма надзвичайно
цікава тим що в ній розглядаються
саме виховній компетентності дітей через
цінності і ціннісні здатності Я
рекомендую ознайомитися з тим хто не
бачив цієї програми її змістом а також
хочу сказати що також мною і
Іваном дмитровичем беком розроблена
також дуже цікава концепція з формування
національно-культурної ідентичних
своїх батьків у сучасних умовах і цю
концепцію також можна знайти
в інтернеті і так само можна знайти в
електронній бібліотеці нашої академії
педагогічних наук України
крім того
науковцями співробітниками інституту
розробляються
змістом методичне забезпечення як і
патріотичного виховання культури і
гідності
формування учнів наприклад
формування в учнів
національно-культурної ідентичності
розроблені нами і
монографії і методичні посібники і
методичні рекомендації з реальними
конкретними розробками що цікаво для
педагогів не тільки школи а їх для
позашкільників які займаються саме таким
вихованням
для цього інститут проблем виховання як
уже зазначалося доповідачами
інтересів участь
у проведенні тренінгів національного
патріотичного виховання разом з Днем
наші тренери
також активно співпрацюють колективом
днем і зуміли підготувати цілу плеяду
крутецьких тренерів з
національно-патріотичного виховання
ту ж не дивно що наші діти сьогодні
також активно включені в цей процес
супротиву
лягаю за тим Як поводяться наші школярі
Я думаю що справді наше виховання є на
високому рівні бо Наші діти не байдужі
до того що відбувається в Україні вони
збирають кошти вони використовують всі
свої засоби вони придумують Вони
працюють над тим щоб щось створити нове
Якось ви допомогти армії і це реально
заслуга наших вихователів Як
позашкільників так і шкільних вчителів
тому що ви очевидно що це є результатом
нашого виховання
Інститут проблем виховання звичайно
розробив він тільки
тренінги Я з Україною в серці там
декілька тих тренінгових програм які
пропонують
скажемо для того щоб для підвищення
кваліфікації а також є
проводився тренінг з громадянського
виховання з розвитку громадянських
компетентностей що є абсолютно
затребувану у наш час
в мене також були розроблені і
проводилися квести як онлайн так і
офлайн і саме цікаво що ці квести не
проводили для студентів для школярів
починаючи з 5 класу там різні квести
різні за змістом і навіть нещодавно наше
спів наскільки провели квест для дітей
біженців у Нідерландах і це було великим
святом що Інститут проблем виховання все
ж таки є знайшов можливість підтримати
наших співвітчизників підтримати наших
дітей в таких умовах і я думаю що такі
квести
також мають право на життя і на те щоб
їх впроваджувати у масову практику
також розроблені нами і майстер-класи
українською і англійською мовою
мабуть із
пані Катерина вона ви нас чуєте
щось сталося зв’язком ми вас не чуємо
Ну тим не менш щось
пані Катерину На жаль регламент
регламент у нас такий що ми вже
вибиваємося з графіку Я думаю що
контакти ваші Які є і та інформація яку
ви нам розказали за вже 10 хвилин вашого
виступу ми вже її отримали і зрозуміли
що вашу внесок те що про що ми сьогодні
говорили і особливо про те що ви чітко
підкреслили що сьогодні багато хто людей
взагалі дізнався що є такий Інститут
проблем виховання от це дуже серйозна
річ і я хочу ще підкреслити наостанок бо
ми маємо вже завершити ми вже більше
трьох годин працюємо хочуть
одну хвилиночку
одну хвилиночку так От я хотіла сказати
про
всеукраїнський стіл з
військово-патріотичного виховання який
об'єднав усіх освітян бо сьогодні
говорили самі про військового
патріотичне виховання і сьогодні триває
робота над концепцією
військово-патріотичного виховання а
також я Хочу наголосити що Інститут
проблем виховання відкритий для усіх
освітян і позашкільників і для співпраці
Дякую за увагу
і ми вам Дякуємо також Дякуємо що
долучилися що знайшли час Отже Шановні
колеги ми завершуємо основну програму
нашої конференції ще раз перед
завершенням Хочу звернути вашу увагу на
два важливих акценти ще раз дуже прошу
Дайте мені слайд з
моделями організації навчання за місцем
перебування це слайд з доповіді нашого
міністра а сьогодні вранці на пленарній
конференції це вашій увазі представлені
моделі організації навчання за місцем
перебування наших вихованців наших колег
освітян і всіх причетних до освітнього
процесу більш детально будь ласка
знаходьте відповіді на деталізацію цих
моделей на сайті Міністерства освіти і
науки України перегляньте ще раз будь
ласка
саму конференцію перегляньте конференції
наших колег з 11 локацій які вже
сьогодні відбулися
обов'язково долучайтеся до флешмобу який
розпочав сьогодні зранку наш міністр
флешмоб Повертайся до навчання хештег
повертайся до навчання Подивіться уважно
конференцію є офіційне відео
Міністерства освіти і науки України за
цим флешмобом Тому перед завершенням Я
хочу надати слово
в нашій гості нашій співорганізаторці
пані Тетяна Юріївна Кононович головний
спеціаліст відділу позашкільної освіти
та виховної роботи Міністерства освіти і
науки України для того аби оголосити
проект рішення нашої конференції
конференції позашкілля 22 безпека і
патріотизм
Доброго дня і так підводячи підсумки
конференції сьогоднішнього дня Це
позашкілля 2022
патріотизм безпеки Я хочу зазначити що
ми підготували проект рішення за
підсумками нашої конференції це перш за
все це реалізація
національно-патріотичного виховання
системи освіти України до 2025 року
також продовжувати роботу щодо стосовно
неприпустимості закриття реорганізація -
це закладів позашкільної освіти взагалі
збереження мережі закладів позашкільної
освіти
внесення відповідних змін до навчальних
програм з позашкільної освіти з
урахуванням роботи в умовах воєнного
стану та надзвичайних ситуацій
посилити роботу з надання вихованням
закладом позашкільної освіти
компетентності необхідних для служби
Збройних Силах України перебування в
умовах воєнного стану надзвичайних
ситуацій
підвищити Престиж праці та соціального
статусу педагогів позашкільників це і
прирівняння тарифних розрядів до
вчителів закладів загальної середньої
освіти тривалість відпустки звільнення
від мобілізації та інше
департаментом освіти і науки обласної
Київської міської державної
адміністрації
сприяти розробленню органами місцевого
самоврядування програм формування в
дорожніх карт тощо розвитку позашкільної
освіти у Переді воєнного часу
дякую Тетяна Юріївна Отже Шановні колеги
я розумію що після такої масштабної
інформативної нашої зустрічі сьогодні
питань більше ніж відповіді але питання
ми з вами вміємо ставити а відповіді на
них ми вміємо знаходити Хочу наголосити
на тому що
Міністерство освіти і науки України де є
відповіді на всі запитання є офіційний
сайт є керівники напрямів є фахівці є
експерти є купа професіоналів людей які
на ці питання зможуть надати відповіді
Наша задача з вами найближчим часом
переглянути матеріали конференції наші
свої обов'язкову переглянути наголошую
переглянути пленарну частину нашого
серпневої конференції і вже влаштуватись
до нового навчального року повертаємося
до навчання це наше мистецтво найближчих
місяців Ну і звичайно не за горами День
незалежності перший день незалежності
України ось в такому військовому стані
тому тримаємося Будьмо свідомі Будьмо
разом бо ми окремо ланка суспільства і
ми саме ті Ковалі щастя дитячого яке
разом з вами ми своїми діями будемо
втілювати в життя втілювати і наближати
нашу перемогу Ми дякуємо що всім хто
сьогодні долучився до конференції наживо
Дякуємо щиро всім тим хто переглядав
нашу трансляцію навіть у каналі
Міністерства Ми дякуємо всім хто буде
поширювати цю інформацію і розповідати
іншим про те що відбувається в Україні і
як
Вони готуються до навчального року
Дякуємо позашкільники ми з вами реально
герої тому тримаємося і чекаємо світлові
миті Слава Україні Героям слава до нових
зустрічей і хай всім щастить